going live is it working
so oh we're almost there
are we there are we going to do it have
we done it have we reached
live status have we done it
knock knock with the devil in malevolent
has ever been
can you guys tell me if we're live i
haven't heard venom in a while
please that's all i want to know all i
care about someone
confirmed are we live one firm comment
going we can hear you would make
the world of difference right now
mothership reported they can hear and
see us we've done it we've done it
that's what i'm talking about people all
right it's gonna be a f
i know right it's all a [ __ ] banana
sandwich right now yes
rest in peace john lewis i gotta get
proper conditioning cream so my
girlfriend thank you guys for being live
uh anissa joshua gabriel horror gamer
richard bentley and angry cool
independer tm nick oh my god so many
names coming in
tongue fun with saying tongue punch fart
box
yes uh no don't worry we'll we'll find a
way to we'll find a way to rap during
this
uh yeah so i kind of just came up with
this topic today but before we go
further
i must acknowledge this situation so my
girlfriend showed me a tick tock video
about curly hair and how to just
naturally let it fall so it's been this
whole process
and i'm still figuring it out so i'm
working with
the work in progress as of today i think
you're getting good responses then no no
no no no no you're just getting used to
it
just just wait john just wait i'm
telling you we're gonna start but
literally
hagrid getting a makeover is this
welcome to your first live video if
you've ever been here before
you're like halfway to chris cornell
though it's perfect you've got that
grungy
like those flowing curls it's beautiful
yeah we'll see we'll see how this goes
anywho sing an audio slave karaoke guys
so this topic today it's a little bit
different
um it's actually very different because
normally we like to just do like
commentary ones
um but i thought this could be a fun one
where we just go off the rails get
creative and see where the [ __ ] we go
from here on out um so yeah picture
cinematic universe i've always
wanted to launch a youtube segment
called picture cinematic universe
but then i thought the joke would get
very old if we did it once a week so i
never did it
so uh yeah and i already see that a
couple of you guys craig looks like a
renaissance painter
that's a great but that is that way who
said that no
science that's a great one all you need
is like a special kind of
hat and it's perfect oh i love that
comment
i i think that's a good compliment and
john has started watching the boys
i am on episode three i'm gonna probably
try and forge ahead a couple this
weekend all right so i got a couple of
cinematic universes in mind
they're the best ones you're ever going
to hear and uh
so why don't we just swing right into
this because this is going to be
different for us as
with this creative one because what we
normally like to do during these streams
and if you're here please hit that like
button it helps notify more people what
we normally like to do
is uh you know like and just engage with
the regular chat
then go to the super chats and then go
to the stream labs one by the way if you
are planning on super chatting
uh much appreciated if you can't that's
okay it's much appreciated and
streamlabs is a preferable method
so we kind of hop around here the whole
time so if you're curious link in the
description
also just hitting the like if you're
here just hit the like button
and you don't want to contribute
monetarily show this hit the like button
it's good for us thank you to those who
already super chatted and contributed in
the stream labs we will get to you
momentarily all right hagrid jr see
beautiful bliss got it
all right so my first one this is a
classic one that i think a lot of people
have wanted to see for a while and this
is one we actually did do a video on
many years ago and i thought would be
the perfect cinematic universe and john
might already know where i'm going with
this yeah
because this is the only one we've done
a video for um
it is uh the nintendo cinematic universe
i've always thought it would be perfect
to do like a mocap
animated type of franchise where you do
mario
you do donkey kong you do zelda you do
them all
and then you bring them all together for
a mario party movie
mario kart i agree
but no for a uh like uh like uh
uh what you call it like a super smash
brothers kind of move where you do have
to fight like a common threat but i
think the
ncu would be
the perfect cinematic universe and
i also think because i i constantly say
that video games would be best
adapted for television constantly say
that
nintendo i think where you're coming
from with that
nintendo i think is the exception i
think nintendo
is the per they have the perfect games
that would work
for trilogies or even one-offs
especially zelda because they kind of
repeat the same story in a lot of their
games
so i think zelda would be a perfect
movie and uh yeah the mario ones as well
but i think
i don't know about them being live
action i think they would have to be
animated or mocap animated to say at the
minimum like in the zemeckis adventures
of tintin kind of style
um yeah that's just basically the first
one i would go with is the nintendo
cinematic universe
that's not a bad call g a couple people
have actually already shouted out my
my like number one wish list
pick for a cinematic universe uh and
that would be in fact i'm gonna go one
further because there's a very general
way to uh
to quantify this but i guess i would go
with uh
scp secure contain protect creepy pastas
in general like i feel like they're
they're really hard to adapt because of
the lack
of uh you know really solid credit that
can be
like a lot of these things are built
over time by many people on message
boards and they're really hard to credit
and thus
they're really hard to adapt because
their rights nightmares but
uh all that stuff aside i would love to
see some kind of scp-themed
creepypasta universe that has yeah some
kind of weigh station which is the scp
that
catalogs and you know contains these
creatures but
you know it just opened you up to so
much and because of the way that
uh internet lore and urban legends have
grown and even
like dark web stuff has grown i feel
like you could have a pretty cool and
not that people haven't attempted to
touch on this in movies but i feel like
that would be
a really cool thing that i would love
like that i would love to be like
involved with if it ever happened
but also that i see people out there
really
like periodically pitching and stuff
like that and even when i was like back
working at blumhouse and stuff like that
when that first slender movie came out
people were like why are there more
creepypasta movies
and uh i i would love for that but also
if we're just talking dreams uh i would
love some kind of just
car cinematic universe where you can get
like fast and furious
need for speed go old school get like
characters from cannonball run or
whatever [ __ ]
and just have them kind of all occupy
one big gear head universe
pair off different characters and stuff
like that uh
because you know all you need is the
cars to tie things together yes
uh and there are tons and tons of you
could get death race characters in there
you could even get death rays 2000 or
the
remake of jason statham in there like
you could get everybody
then you could get it confusing and have
shaw and jason statham from the death
race remake and and do whole eddie
murphy type thing
possibilities are endless i feel like we
are on our way to a biopic cinematic
universe
with elton john and mercury freddie
mercury what was it freddy freeman
um freddie freeze remember freddy
freeman super hero
also real by biopic universe yeah man
what if superheroes visited classic
historical figures
and then i'm seeing a lot of love for
like things like the gi joe universe
in here um and then the stephen king
cinematic universe is another one that
i'm surprised they haven't
tried doing yet with the amount of
stephen king products out there one dark
the dark tower is supposed to open the
door for that
it's just the movie itself was not great
yeah
what i would also like to see is um the
friends
cinematic universe where you do
spin-offs of each of the characters
after the finale of friends many years
later i wouldn't do this hbo max reunion
what i would do is i would go into
uh like the life of ross and rachel
right afterwards
right and they have a domestically
violent relationship because let's face
it they've been a toxic couple since the
beginning
and then i would do chandler monica and
the family life they have and joey
is matt leblanc essentially in real life
so you go through all these
individuals and then you bring them
together for a movie
showing the only way they can really be
happy
is when they're all together and their
only option is to
live in a couple small apartments yeah
across the hall
forever i think you do like an attack on
titan cinematic universe and stuff but
guys
we have to honor some of these super
chester to come in and the transformers
one is one that i think they've been
trying to build up to but unfortunately
bumblebee didn't perform as high as i
wanted it to i'm going to nip this in
the bud stealth striker
we saw the halloween kills teaser yeah
we're interested in we're going to keep
asking don't worry not
that much to cover on the channel people
will keep asking
it is castle rock is based on stephen
king mark leech
but we got a couple of super chats in
here just a couple just a couple lucky
look
uh so let's see here the agoraphobic
fanboy
okay hey oh should we should we do our
freestyle shout outs
oh yeah we have to should we do our
freestyle shout outs guys
it's a staple of the channel now oh now
we have to do our freestyle shout outs
and if this is your first time here
you're in for
an awakening of the greatest hip-hop
artist to have ever existed
in this time yeah okay
agoraphobic certainly not homophobic
um i go around here and sometimes my
rhymes sound rhetoric
he's a fanboy a boy who likes to destroy
a boy who never can annoy but i gotta
tell you agoraphobic fanboy
it brings me so much joy and then one
day the military will deploy you out
there
agoraphobic uh-oh but what happens to
you when i
show that i am not stoic okay we're
warming up that was the first one that
was great that was the first
those were the easiest way to let loose
right here if not bars
or at least sticks or something man
those were at least you know
what did he say john he said i would
take thank you agoraphobic fanboy by the
way
i would take just one movie from this
series
okay but bioshock has so many
storytelling opportunities only three
games but such a deep concept and mythos
and
uh i'm actually of all the video games
out there i'm surprised
that not more has buzzed around the idea
of
a bioshock adaptation of any kind
because
that movie that game sorry has such an
expansive
lore and world and mythology and all
that stuff and even though
um the one i can't remember what the
subtitle was but the one that takes
place in the air city
uh even though that didn't get as well
received i feel like there's still a ton
of imaginative stuff you could do in
that world yeah man
so yeah i'm frankly surprised it's not
happening in any way
i like your bioshock idea i think you do
that with so many video games actually
like the nintendo cinematic universe
mario zelda
no i do think that you could do that
with um
uh uh i i wait what was this called
loving the lack and improvement
since the live stream the last stream
what does that mean
[Laughter]
in which respect uh yeah no the bioshock
one sure i think you could do that but i
think with like many video games it does
open up the door where you can develop
so many cinematic universes and i think
generally speaking even with comic books
you can do that as well
like with comic books one thing i've
always wanted to see done
is the batman universe and i think
they're kind of trying to build that
up but in a weird way i feel like you
could have just started with batman then
eventually built into
like focus on your batman franchise and
then have like your subside ones like
with nightwing when rock
like you have a perfect segue to build
your universe if
robin goes all right i don't want to be
robin anymore i'm going to be nightwing
and bloodhaven and then you do your
nightwing franchise you do your bat
girlfriend you could
and then you have them all come together
for your arkham asylum movie where the
bat family versus everyone
in arkham asylum that's what i've always
wanted to see done don't know why it
hasn't been done before yet
boogie um but thank you agoraphobic
fanboy
oh oh look who it is it's rizzo gaming
john take it away with the freestyles yo
i'm about to be flaming
y'all with my rhymes about rizzo gaming
i'm gonna be maiming your eardrums
don't be humble son because it's time to
answer your question
or your comment to the left mine would
be
van helsing or league of extraordinary
gentlemen as i feel both would lend
themselves well
to a fun action-filled mythological
universe
i exact i agree and i would love
actually to see another take on a van
helsing universe
wait a minute i could see a van helsing
universe
the dark universe and you bring them all
together what would your
league of extraordinary gentlemen
universe be though isn't it just the
league of extraordinary in general
because they're already pulling
from so many characters in the league of
extraordinary gentlemen
like tom sawyer like captain nemo
like dory and gray people who already
have their own like literature
novels yeah yeah so what would your
cinema
already like a literature cinematic
universe yourself
already doing league of extraordinary
gentlemen is already the cinematic
universe crossover in and of itself
that if you were to do like your solo
unless you're like intentionally
adapting a 20 000 leagues under the sea
oh we're just getting warmed up today
buddy
what else they're doing at 20 000
leagues under the sea
and then uh like your dorian gray movie
like you're doing all these
solo entries to build up to the league
of extraordinary gentlemen
but what would those cliffhangers be i
don't know cuz you got like jekyll and
hyde in there
yeah hey it beats me that's why we got
to build this cinematic universe out go
back read those rocks find ways of
bending and twisting them and never
actually putting in enough themes to
give them an impactful ending
and we can make them forever well [ __ ] i
like your idea though rizzo gaming i
think we should go for it
i'm a fan um and yes uh
i see in the chat lorenzo is saying uh a
universe based on hp lovecraft's
characters i would love to see that and
i feel like they've been trying to get
to that for a while
who's next oh we got romero sanchez
okay all right i'm looking at my homeboy
ramiro
he gives me a dirty look as if he's
robert de niro
and i want to go after him but i use my
g
ass like zero and i fight at him
under the sea like captain nemo
al pacino we got it rhymes rizzo gaming
ramirez ramirez sanchez thank you my
darling
long time fan just want to say thanks
for all the funny content
i was giving you some serious bars just
there man yeah
i would not chalk it up to funny but
thank you
i appreciate the super chat though buddy
yes thank you so much for your love and
support
uh we want to do one more yes do one
let's do a couple more
more we got beautiful bliss i want to
give a kiss to beautiful bliss
i never feel remiss when i get around
beautiful bliss
and sometimes i feel like i do miss my
beautiful bliss
and i want to put you on my christmas
wish list cause i love you beautiful
bliss
give us a kiss ghost rider you've never
kissed this whole time it's all good
all those words that i didn't use that's
what i'm here for i'm here to catch the
one rhyme that was dangling hayden i see
your chat don't worry
i'm gonna get you we're just getting
warmed up and hello jenna randolph
welcome
hey jenna ghostwriter universe done
better as much as i love
nicholas cage i'll i'll go down for that
yeah let's do it newton ghost writer
world
i i genuinely think with most every
comic book character
as much as we love laughing at whatever
the [ __ ] is going on with
sony and marvel because it's just so
weird and confusing and they don't seem
like they're really ever on the same
page sometimes
they're on to something with their
spider-man cinematic universe because
every single character has their own
cinematic universe
built into the dna automatically they do
and ghost writer especially you know
opening up the gates of hell and all the
amount of characters that come through
there uh
yeah i could totally see it working i
could totally see it happening man
and then let's go let's go one more we
got will herren
all right john take it away will heron
flying high like the red baron
faster than a mclaren tearing through
the city
streets with fat beats and retracting
his message message retracted the best
kind of super chat boom
ain't no idea what you said because we
don't have the size [ __ ]
all we gotta say is thank you thank you
buddy
thank you buddy who's next electric
lizard
king gizzard and the lizard wizard it's
a real band
is a real band from australia looking at
my homeboy electric
my mind's feeling a little bit hectic
and i get around here my heart beats so
eclectic
you're so electric eclectic wait no i
[ __ ] that up
my mind's becoming a little bit manic
that's fine safe that's good it's a good
safe you saved those bars from being
tragic
a collaboration
thank you did you guys catch that
i don't know if you guys caught that
there was a rhyme there
you saved those bars for being tragic
i'm waiting for the laugh track on my
hilarity
oh i heard everybody screaming oh in my
head
uh electric wizard thank you so much and
uh electric wizard wants a collab
of brandon rogers universe and the mcu
brandon rogers is brandon rogers that
[ __ ] like creepy ass
dude or am i thinking of someone coming
i would love i don't i want who you're
thinking of
i'm thinking of like a killer oh god i
hope not
brandon rogers oh no he's a youtuber
i was i was totally thinking of this the
santa barbara killer
oh no no that wouldn't be good i mean
that was roger's brandon
i mean i'm sure it would be cathartic to
watch the avengers
you know murder a a terrible
human person but also i think it would
be a little dark for what marvel wants
to go for oh that would be funny
um but yeah we talked about water
bubbles in the chat we talked about all
right let's do one more
water bottle we got one more roman m
roman with two a's roman
roma there's a roman or roman it could
be roman
okay
we rolling ancient like romans patient
oh it's good strolling through the city
streets with fat beats
these rhymes repeat that's how they stay
sick
thick is a brick my dick's growing my
dick roman
for roman and
showing mr roman
today hi guys because of how great dr
doom story in the comics do you think he
deserves his own standalone film in the
mcu oh that'd be cool
i think that could be interesting
actually i mean it wouldn't be anything
i i don't want to draw a stylistic
comparison but it could be like the mcu
joker in a totally other
flavor yeah we're victor von doom is a
struggling standard comedy wow
in 1980s new york right
completely grounded no supers
nothing no inhumans nothing everyone
always treats me weird because
my last name's doom people think i have
ill intent
because of this name i have um
yeah i would love a solo victor von doom
movie why the [ __ ] not
at this point i know what you should do
you should do your fantastic four movie
right just do that fantastic four no
victor von doom
and then you do your sequel we're 20
minutes in
all the fantastic four get beaten to
death by a golf club
with and you could just call it
fantastic four two
they all get beaten to death with a golf
club and then you focus on victor von
doom for the rest of the movie
and you know what you could call it
fantastic
four because of the golf club and you
shout four when you're golfing oh that's
really good job that's a great
timeless joke
all right so here we go all right john
let's take this away
i see jenna randolph in the in the chat
once a
a kingsman mcu crossover all right yeah
what are you guys saying in the chat
that's a good one
i saw that uh somebody said that john
and greg are the new eminem in 50 cent
and i just want to know which of us is
50 and which one of us is m
[ __ ] that we're our own thing yeah
that's eminem and 50 cent got nothing
no no it's not [ __ ] they're not even
in the same lane
that we are all right they're not trying
to do the same kind of
conscious raps we're making actually
someone in the chat did bring up an
hp lovecraft cinematic universe and so
much anytime you see like weird
fantastical supernatural like creatures
and
so lovecraftian anything with tentacles
you know literally anything with
tentacles people say that yeah
um stephen king mo uh he said that he's
primarily inspired by hp lovecraft and
hp lovecraft if you just adapt his
novels you have a cinematic universe
it's
that simple yeah because they're all
tied together they're all yeah in this
world that has these elder gods yeah
yeah these creature gods so i don't know
why they haven't done it yet
i think it's just that thing and i think
the bubble will break eventually because
they keep making more and more lovecraft
theme like
independent movies that get a lot of
love so i feel like at some point now
we're gonna get some kind of high scale
there's a
minecraft movie coming out oh i love
kevin's comment kevin shepard in the
chat he's saying um
all 824 movies is one world yeah i mean
whenever i watch an a24 trailer i'm like
you don't have to show me that it says
a24 at the beginning i could watch a
trailer without that and go this is
probably
this is an a24 movie isn't it yeah you
can just tell you can just
feel it yeah i think i i sorry
i caught uh uh jenna again i think that
actually like at first i was like i
don't know about that but i feel like if
you have some kind of like high-powered
secret agent-ness that's
you know a little bit more heightened
because i always feel like the regular
people who work at shield or like
regular
right so if you had like a kingsman
style marvel thing but that's kind of
what agents of shield is anyway so
that's fair you know but yeah um i would
love for
uh the kingsman to cross over into the
mcu but i think i think kingsman worked
better crossing over into the dc
universe jenna randolph
see there is there's a dream i have had
for the longest time where the pacific
rim
and terminator universes cross over and
then you could cross those over with
transformers
right yeah oh we should have done this
topic i know crosstalk
views that should cross over next week
how do we change the title right now on
this video
movies that should cross over is there a
way to do that
no there's a way to make a new graphic
but i don't know if there's a way to
make it because that would have been a
much better topic we should have
discussed this further john you know
it's okay um yeah we'll make it through
i would love to see what else are we
getting from the chat oh wait wait we
got a couple of stream labs in here that
we got to acknowledge here yeah
a couple people have said a tarantino
universe although i feel like a
tarantino universe is already a thing
i feel like he he has already done stuff
to connect all those movies together
about that victor i think tarantino's
often presented questions and then he
realizes he can connect them
but you have uh i don't know what would
be a cool cinematic universe
is if they did a zorro franchise and
then at the
third movie you find out it's in the
django universe
you don't wait till the first movie you
do it in the third movie where you're at
where then you find out they're in the
django universe yes
i like that yeah that'd be cool okay
parenthesis this is picture cinematic
universe
parenthesis movies that should cross
over
this is movies this should cross over
what's up erica watching from the pool
wow that's
that's how you felt nice eric fancy
schmidt erica
what it do all right okay all right we
should
like robocop and terminator is someone
just brought up in the chat why haven't
they crossed over that would be great
all right john let's do this we got
thank you for the guys who took time out
of your
day out of this stream to go over to the
stream labs because i know it can be a
little
convenient clicking on an additional
link but it does help
so we got flev doran i think flev doran
if i skimmed this correctly when you
were moving it over here he's got three
in a row but they're all
part of the same same comment door
all right we're not showing favoritism
we're just it's just one long comment
divided up by
three separate one dollar contributions
it's just flev doran
flooring us with generosity oh
john curiosity for what he has to say
oh my god john what question does he
have for
us
yeah because we got a new topic
sometimes i
start snoring but it can never be boring
when i'm around my homeboy flev
doran boom
that's all you need that's all you
[ __ ] need that's it enough rhymes
no more so first off we got hi guys
let's read it all as one bit big bit
all right here we go hi guys quick off
topic i got a great laugh after you read
my
question in last week's patreon q a and
wondered
about my gender and you settled on
pansexual based on my avatar
since we are in the inclusivity era uh
in movies i turn into a hate comment i'm
so worried i'm not sure but
it'll make for good live content yeah
since we are in the inclusivity era
in movies i would like to see a fast and
furious ish
type franchise but done right do it like
the early
do it like in the early years of the mcu
when we weren't sure what was to come of
it
have a few different action films
different
actors don't hint that they are
connected until you do the big avengers
film wait a minute what does this have
to do with inclusivity though
um i guess because the fast and furious
cast is already so
varied in terms of ethnicity you've got
several people of color on the cast
maybe
flev's idea is to give you know we get
like a a letty movie
and then a roman music okay and then a
dom movie
you know who would really appreciate
this is tyrese gibson
tyree's tire is gonna be the iron man
where he's got two movies before this
franchise has even collided yet sorry
thank you so much
are you waiting for this i just built a
new pool
i gotta can't stop spending my
money thank you
[Music]
i think that would be i don't think
people would care
i don't they were solo films of the fast
and furious characters
i'm sad i think it's that's the problem
uh yeah i really don't fast and the
furious wouldn't have been this way if
it hadn't been a point break remake from
the get-go
people loved that because of
ensemble-based or team-up based i don't
think they would like it if it was
the whole point is that we got a film
and and paul walker to hook up we we got
to want that and we can't do that if
they're just in solo films that's very
true that's right
very true very very very cool but
appreciate the comment flav doran i love
you phleb and we're in we're
no closer to knowing the truth of what
flev identifies as
one time i went bowling with a man named
jason dolan
his penis started growing and then my
rhyme started flowing
as i was hanging out with jason dolan my
man jason can sometimes be a free
mason and then we smoke weed together he
starts lacing
jason dolan you got my vote when we
poland oh
i want a cinematic la buddy cop universe
that includes rigs and murtaugh
john mcclane and al powell
axel foley taggart and
rosewood and they are battling ocp who's
taking over los angeles with their ed 20
wait what 209 209
209's and they all have to be turned
into robocops
dude jason dolan is a screenwriter
i feel like he's just trying to get his
spec screenplay out there for everyone
to know about right now
yeah jason so if anybody wants to see
this movie jason has an indiegogo set up
yeah fun to script yourself i mean that
would be a fun idea
i would have a great honestly like i
think that would make
if we really started tearing walls down
i think it would be funny if we just
took occupations as licensed to do
cinematic universes and yeah we just
have buddy cops team up or we have like
different space travel guys or different
street racers team up or whatever
i would love to see if eddie i would
just love to see if eddie murphy and mel
gibson
get along together behind the scenes
i feel like eddie murphy stands his
ground tells tells it how it is
and i feel like mel is likely to slip up
on something
and that would just be entertaining news
to talk about and the quartering would
love it
that's what i have uh yeah quartering
leaks geeks and gamers they would all
eat that up
that'd be great is there a name for that
genre of content or that or that niche
of
mimi wants us to leave tyreese alone
outrage
out commentary anti-justice warriors
no i mean uh they don't present
themselves as that they present
themselves as people who
um want to talk about the fallacies
that's going wrong
and pop culture world but they need
help they need the outrage in order to
keep
ironic part right um okay let's go here
uh oh and harry potter doctor who
universe that'd be cool what a great
topic
heck yeah harry potter doctor who i also
saw another one
the accountant means jason bourne so
whenever this graphic
is on screen that means we're looking
just solely on the chat right now chat
and i saw one for twisted metal which
i hadn't thought of but twisted metal
has a lot of eccentric characters it's
got
car racing but also demolition it's a
little death race but i feel like that
could work
oh my god i just missed a comment but
someone said a ryan gosling cinematic
universe
just uh i just can't wait for the hero
shot where were the cameras circling
around them and they're all
on your left staring at each other and
then five more goslings coming in
i don't know that would be so funny and
then finally one of them just to the
other
you want to fight
[Laughter]
that would be entertaining as [ __ ] i
would love that um
okay and then uh why did they stop
making lego movies because they they
went really hard out the gate with a
giant success and then people were like
yeah but like
this one flavor isn't enough to carry an
entire just
endless franchise total recall in the
matrix crossing over that would act cool
if you did all those movies total recall
the matrix the 13th floor
dark city dark city blade runner
blade runner sure gently is the one
yes definitely just throw it in there
yeah and he might as well make it happen
lawn mower man lawnmower man oh my god
that'd be so great
yeah the ninth gate
that would be so funny that would be
funny i would like it
i see a lot of people actually getting
really on board with this buddy cop
crossover movie that jason dolan picked
it's a good idea no it's a good idea
because it it implies
a job and a dynamic and and the thing is
like it implies a certain set of rules
like all these buddy cop movies
exist under relatively similar physics
and that's why it would work so well i
think because you know you have
the same protocol they're always up
against the same thing
you know the chief is like you know so
then
we just watch as they you know piss off
like the head of the fbi or something
instead of the chief
police based off water bubbles latest
comment
toy story and child's play crossing over
with each other
would be perfect we're waiting
i don't know why there isn't some
terrible youtube fan film made about
this just yet
and like i'm sure somebody's got the
animation chops to make it happen
right right you know i that those are
those are ones that are too perfect
people someone was saying star wars and
alien i want to talk about the star wars
universe really fast i don't think the
xenomorphs would make it
we're getting to the point with the star
wars spin-offs where
they're going to announce a new show
where it's going to be like remember
this guy in that episode who was in the
background
he's getting a show got a new [ __ ]
show
he's the key to understanding the entire
star wars universe
and we're not going to stop until you
know every piece of extended
facts remember that droid
yeah he's got he's got a show now he's
got a whole franchise
that's the star wars universe we're on
to i want the star wars marketing
universe where like
it's literally just like a boardroom
drama where people are trying to figure
out how best to sell their toys
all right john let's get back to the to
the super chats here but thank you
oh wait a minute a buffy the vampire
slayer
universe would work for the movies
mm-hmm
i think for the films and you know who
should helmet the beloved jostlers
who everyone loves working with and has
nothing but good things
i haven't heard i haven't read any of
the articles of joss whedon
but i just keep seeing his name entitled
so i'm assuming it's all positive things
about
joss whedon as late that's how the media
works these days
i i didn't i mean this is not me taking
the entire comment
sorry ethan holgate i mean as much as i
would love to see george butler play
solid snake i just think a gerard butler
cinematic universe where all of
butler's characters exist caught the
american accent
the scottish mushmouth american accent
i'm gerard butler yeah the president has
been taken
i i am a law-abiding citizen i am from
oakland
i'm doing a new york accent
are you talking to me i'm the only one
here
so i can assume you're talking to me
guys we need to get insane in here start
pitching the most absurd cinematic
universes you could think of
will harry thank you everyone as we
contribute to the super chat really
appreciate it
will heron registering complaints like a
karen
12 lives like in a harem pants
water in the plants doing a dance and
asking us some questions
actually thank you for your contribution
uh great biopic cinematic universe on
artists like kanye west bob
dylan sufian stevens david bowie radio
head kendrick lamar fk twigs etc
wait a minute so with your cinematic
universe bro appreciate the super chat
are you planning on crossing over all
these characters
into your cinematic like this is a cool
playlist
but also i want to i want a full
breakdown because what i don't know what
these artists really have to do with
what one another
yes other than like it would be
theoretically cool to hear several of
them cross over with each other and
collaborate
uh but i guess are you just simply
naming
uh options and saying that every
musician
could theoretically i want to do yeah
let's do a musical biopic
universe but where are your stories
cinematic universe
true story cinematic universe but where
you're never ever bound to the era those
characters actually
lived in right you can have anybody meet
anybody
you can have mozart meet david bowie and
it'll be fine
and they'll have you know some kind of
clash because their sensibilities fish
out of water man who fell from earth
blah blah blah there you go
great ideas john thank you great idea
these are my ideas these are my ideas
who's next here thank you will
pablo m okay all right
i ride around in my el diablo as i hang
out with homeboy pablo
he touches my dick yet says no homo and
i say
whoa let's take it slow-mo and then he
gives me a blow-blow
pablo you got a blow job shout out
thanks buddy
what did he say today playing guitar and
a doe bro
uh i always had the idea of making
biopics for bands
like biopic [ __ ] is going off the train
let's stream today let's see what kind
of list we get here though i always
have everyone wants a biopic cinematic
universe
make it biopics for bands like credence
clearwater revival janice joplin
santana speaking of which santana if
you're a jojo's bizarre adventurer fan
we just met that character
uh santana the who jefferson airplane
etc
all culminating in a woodstock film
absolutely it's actually a solid not bad
that's not a bad idea well the thing
with the you could
realistically out of these like joking
biopic
cinematic universes musical biopics
is the way you can do it because so many
of them collaborate
they rise up together at the same time
and there's so many eras of music with
so many parallel acts
even [ __ ] straight out of compton
seemed like they were setting up a
cinematic universe
you got snoop dogg
yeah and then like [ __ ] uh dre at the
end i'm starting my own business what's
it called
aftermath smash black
so even with there it seemed like they
were setting up some type of cinematic
universe and musical biopics
actually you know what yeah because in
in musical i'm doing my campy up
finger not in musical biopics
they uh they do always have
like other famous people other like
famous celebrities here in the champions
league
you do always have like these other
famous people
show up at one point so it's like a
funny little easter egg
um and so yeah actually musical biopics
you could
i i'm surprised i haven't attempted it
yet because
i think that it's been in it's like in
the dna of biopics
of musical artists specifically yeah and
i feel like they're
you know i mean i understand definitely
the idea that we're making a biopic we
want to focus on one person but i
i wonder what would happen if we started
approaching these more like
you know a collective biopic of you know
a few very
prominent figures in a scene at a
certain time or something like that like
that could be
that could get around perhaps and open
up some new storytelling flavors to
alleviate that walk hard syndrome
exactly you know why is gavin saying i
be michael bandy or michael bay origin
story i mean i play it
you look blow some [ __ ] up now wash my
car
you got the job do you hear that
actually megan fox finally commented on
that uh whole rumor about her washing
his car
for the uh audition basically she was
like they had me
work on the car but i wasn't in a bikini
and it
basically it was it was basically to say
like the story wasn't as creepy as it
sounds i wasn't like in a bikini being
shot like washing a car it was like
they had me work under the hood of like
a car on a lot
it wasn't like at his house or whatever
you know they had me go under the car
and actually replace the engine
it was real mechanical free labor out of
me yeah
i was wearing overalls fully clothed
yeah protective mask
so i don't know what this rumor is yeah
she was like the character's supposed to
know how to fix cars so they wanted me
so i was like oh
this is like the weirdest character
cleanup piece i've read in a while
all right so we got another comment here
dan lane
dan lane what's his comment i'm going
insane over these comments from dan lane
greg take it away
okay greg rap about being
epileptic for 21 years about me being
epileptic for 21 years
they were accusing me of something and
getting my second brain surgery and yes
you have to insert the phrase world's
great
vibrator okay
all right i created a monster this is
the uh this is jimmy fallon's freestyle
game now at this point
yeah if you need to be
okay okay
um the world's least hate
hater is also not the world's great
vibrator
i call him the man dan lane who always
puts me in the right set of my brain
and i go around here and i lift him up
like he's pulling me up on a crane
he wants you to rap about him being
epileptic
well you know what sometimes it can be
being
narcoleptic and sometimes
i think he might be a beast but he's one
of the ones that would qualify as
fantastic
he's got a second brain surgery
and he wants me to shout him out my
name's gregory
but with this brain surgery i feel like
this is just a big chapter in his
history
that's that's fine dan lane so you have
a cinematic universe
do do you have a maybe it's a medical
cinematic universe
i try dan lane and dan lane is the hero
i try
appreciate the super chat buddy and of
course
oligarch all right except for oligarchs
all right yo
so not all right i gotta redeem myself
here you got it you got this i got my
home girl anissa
oliva i want to smoke her up and get me
high like a sativa
she calms me down as if i've just
injected some
indica let's take a trip let's
behave like we're going to bolivia who
her name also looks like my girlfriend's
name olivia
does it does we did it once upon a time
i almost said
lane said no i'm good
no i'm good thanks damn thank you dad
oh much love today i'm good i tried
buddy
what did he what denise is saying and he
says hi greg hi
john hi anisa i want to see a monster
squad universe my movie means so much to
me i would have loved to see
more to it another one killer clowns
from outer space
another one of my faves dude have you
seen monster squad john
yes i have all right john let's talk
about your monster squad universe pitch
it
if you can rely on jon for one thing it
is to ramble about something so go sean
i mean monster squad lends itself well
because you have i mean you've got this
group of kids at the center of it we
could age with them
if you wanted to of course we'd have to
reboot it by now because they're all
much older um but the it's already a
cinematic universe type crossover you
have
the gill man you have a dracula you have
a werewolf you know you've got a
frankenstein monster
so you all you'd have to do is give each
of those characters maybe some kind of
solo thing or hey do the first group
and then have the kids move on and meet
some other bevy
of horror movie monsters but the monster
squad that could be their whole shtick
is their
they're outnumbered and they're a little
in above their heads because they're
young people but
also they get the job done and the wolf
man still has nards
very good wolf man's got nothing you did
it john you did exactly what i said you
would do thanks man
you rambled promise deliver
let's do one more then we're gonna go
back to the chat and then we gotta look
at some of the stream labs
living freak character with the beak
sitting on elm street like a nightmare
glaring at me asking where are you going
so late at night humphrey i'm going to
answer your question
havoc living freak reeks ooh
i'm the opposite of zelda you can call
me shriek
i gotta go take a leak but now we doing
a live stream
so i'll just let my peepee have a little
peek on my
mcu onslaught saga or pulp hero
universe clarify what that means for me
john what's gonna say are these real
things
let's see cuz like there are old like
pulp graphic novels and stuff like that
that would make for their own
neat little universe that would just be
a cool
way to go back uh you know
to an older sensibility and whatnot pulp
magazine so
are you talking about like oh yeah okay
cool yeah yeah
honestly i mean i would love personally
to see them
i mean some comics that aren't marvel dc
this is where we got that popped up for
us right there yeah
oh good thinking yeah um so i think that
could be cool i'm not sure what uh
the mcu onslaught saga is i'm sure you
do gregory because you
have way more nerd than you yeah john i
totally
know exactly what to talk about so uh
i'm just gonna update my own stuff
john is doing this for himself i know
exactly what he said
was written as a sentient psionic entity
created from the consciousness of two
mutants
xavier and magneto that would actually
be something i mean like i don't know if
i would want it to just be its own
cinematic universe but to see that
character and that
story come to life i think would be
fascinating especially because
xavier and magneto are like the two
consistent elements
of every x-men film we've had so well
thanks living freak thanks a great call
and you're not well you might be a freak
and then last one
last one right now and then we'll come
back to you in the super chat in just a
bit
eric horseman he's buff like a norseman
wanna cradle his rippling muscles
in a force field so that no one can ever
touch him
not except for me on eric's pp says hey
hey fam hey fam thanks eric horseman
hello
hello eric thanks buddy it's good to
hear from you
always nice to hear from you and then
we'll take a couple of stream labs we're
going to go back to the
the chat in just a bit oh we got one
from kb
all right oh did i lose it kb laughing
like he he
greg's got a pp and maybe this
question's long enough that while i
read three pee-pees we've had tomorrow
i'll take all those p's back out
we got a hallmark you're an og about the
p-page
you know me all about the pee-pee
big fan of r kelly jb oh no
hallmark christmas movie universe thank
you kb
uh the uh they finally assemble for a
giant snowball fight and baby showers
seriously though i think a greek and or
north mythology universe could be
re-created properly you could of course
do a greek and norse mythology universe
most definitely in thor do it in the mcu
well that but also i feel like i mean
you know clash of the titans is the
thing and the remake of clash of the
titans wasn't the greatest
so you know there's still opportunity
there if they made actual films about
like
the different gods or something like
that yes they found a way to do that
that
could be interesting as a historical
universe i have
always wanted and you're speaking of the
holida
what do you say uh hallmark channel i've
always wanted to see
a santa movie and a krampus movie
and then they go toe-to-toe at the north
pole in the third
movie yeah how great would that be guys
don't tell me you wouldn't watch that
[ __ ]
i mean i know you wouldn't watch that
third movie just don't tell me you would
have watched
a movie i know what it's called it's
called boxing day
it has to be called because that's the
day after christmas and they're going to
fight
santa and krampus ah yes and
this would be funnier if you knew what
boxing is
if you lived in canada everyone knows
for boxing day
everyone we don't do it in america
because we love to get
[ __ ] and we don't send it back oh yeah
man that's where we roll that's how we
do who said that comment
thanks kb that's right all the pee-pee
comments yes the ppe of the kbs
uh we got hitman hudson next
okay hitman hudson you got any rhymes
for
amen hitman hudson
i could be sherlock you could be my
watson and
i i i i wear a mask
call you phantasm i like it
and you could suck up my johnson hitman
hudson
there we go boom we did it guys with the
success of hamilton thank you oh we
couldn't ride hitman hudson and [ __ ]
hamilton
hitman hamilton with the success of
hamilton i'm pitching a cinematic
universe built on biopics of famous
historical figures oh no
there will be a post-credits scene in
each of these bio books in which they
are resurrected with super powers
to face yes ominous threat this is a one
of
two uh oh so i'm gonna
jump up because this is clearly meant to
be connected
okay so we will have to oreo our way
back in in a few minutes but uh he says
i'm thinking harriet tubman
john brown robin hood
jackie robinson pocahontas etc
whoa that would be pretty sweet that
would be a fresh take on like a league
of extraordinary gentlemen but with real
life historical figures
and robin hood i like it wait is robin
hood a real person
that's not i thought was fictional i
think robin hood is
it might be one of those things where
robin hood is based on like an
amalgamation of
real ideas or some [ __ ] like that but i
feel like robin hood is a focus now was
abraham lincoln real
no yeah i've always thought that but i'm
not too afraid to say it out loud
okay all right so he's from bill and ted
all right
yeah yeah yeah bill and ted this is
where they made a vampire hunter movie
dude it's just really
the spin off vampires 20 years later
yeah actually i really like your idea i
would love to watch you
that would be a great red box rental
you sure it would be or a blockbuster
video rental if they still
oh john don't bring me down don't bring
me down
well we already flashed their name so we
might as well do these rat do the other
okay so we got it wait do we already do
we did eric
eric horseman eric horstmann don't have
no fear
eric was here he probably right now he's
drinking a beer and shedding some tears
he approaches me with all this money
like king lear
seeing dead people like cole seer he
likes to take it up the rear
because he's actually gay and he's okay
with the gay jokes that's the cool thing
eric has a real rejects tattoo yeah so
we need to make the gay jokes
and we just got we just got an offer for
an opportunity in which we could make
our own temporary tattoos
so i'm thinking one of eric horseman
not the real rejects logo no yeah we'll
get one of eric an outline uh he says
don't have a question
just hey thanks eric it's really sweet
of you dude hey eric
how's it going appreciate you being here
ethan holgate
oh this is what i've been waiting for
what are you saying right here jump on
it
um oh hold the gate for ethan holgate
there's one really obvious rhyme with
holgate which one
take it away don't be i was brushing my
teeth with colgate and i saw my man
ethan holgate looking at him in the
mirror i started to masturbate
and then i realized this man is part of
my fate
mm-hmm part of it yeah and then i saw
him get in the mail a box of loot crate
yes and he lives in some mysterious
state
[Music]
hi guys thank you ethan
hi guys i think a yu-gi-oh cinematic
franchise based on the original series
would translate to live action well if
done right
also i think netflix should do what
canon films did in the 80s not a
cinematic franchise pitch just something
i'd like to see okay wait what's the
what's the latter part of this comment
okay so i'm a mile i'm at least a bit
familiar with canon films and i mean
they've made a lot of
kind of prolific uh you know
camping and and you know i'm surprised
we have a movie
gotten as much about um the the anime
pitches because anime lends itself to so
much cinematic universe potential
doesn't it
it does i feel like they even do like so
many spin-offs within the anime genre
and then a lot of times this anime ends
and they're like i'm doing a movie
and we've got a new series based on the
same idea under a different subtitle and
we're going to attack outside junior now
yeah yeah yeah see like i it's we are
asked this question about like my hero
academias
uh specifically and i was the the
question was actually about
um how would you adapt like an anime
into a live-action
film and of course i was saying you know
you got to trim some stuff
out you can't like the problem that
often happens is lack of focus it's not
just about aesthetically pleasing
it's also about telling a damn good
narrative which is really important
and i feel like you could do an all
might movie and then do a my hero
academia movie or vice versa
to some certain extent especially with
something like my hero academia or even
attack on titan
like an attack on titan in its latest
season not the one that hasn't debuted
obviously but it's latest season you
have a whole
two episodes two episodes dedicated to
on the story
of aaron's father and i'm like right
there there was a movie
in and of itself you know so i i think
it's like you get into the
argument of like what's a spin-off and
what's a cinematic universe thing
but within this discussion of cinematic
universe i think you can do that with
anime especially
mm-hmm see i'd be fascinated i'm doing
like the vaguest amount of sidebar
research here because i remember
uh we ran a couple pieces on canon films
back when i was working at blumhouse.com
and they are like golden globus and uh
canon
are pretty prolific purveyors of
i mean they did all kinds of stuff they
did like schlocky horror stuff they did
things based on hercules
so uh and they also i believe oh that's
what happened sorry
i believe at one point or another they
had an actual like netflix-esque
mail order uh quality where they would
like acquire films and put them
out so uh if that's anywhere near what
you're uh referencing there with canon i
think that would be cool especially
because netflix i mean you know
they produce so much content i'm
surprised we haven't gotten more
um like i'm surprised anime itself
doesn't just cross over with them
with themselves in that often yeah
because there's so many things that are
like
that are sim like there are so many uh
um
you know spiritual factions of
energy projection and stuff like you
know you have men
in one series and heyman and another and
all these sorts of things and yeah you
could get these characters easily
crossing over because like
one name for one thing might you know
it's like these different powers might
equal the same thing just with different
names yeah absolutely yeah
and there are so many that share like
components like you could get all the
mech suit shows together or something
like that you know
all right guys let's see what's going on
in the chat right now
ice sharknado is its own cinematic
universe bling i also see a lot of uh
shouts out for a will smith cinematic
universe where i'm gonna go back a
little bit and let's just
see where we're at here i've seen a lot
of things meets john wick
a stormtrooper movie i think it would be
cool
we'll call it stormtrooper learning to
aim yeah
this is one really long montage
and then at the end of the movie he's
tasked with training the second
stormtrooper of how to really aim
at inception it mark leeches an
inception in nightmare and elm street
crossover that would be cool that would
be pretty sweet
yeah if you brought in the i i would
watch an inception sequel if you brought
in that aspect we're like two people are
going in at once
and you have some sort of nightmare
element to it and you got dicaprio
talking to freddy krueger how great
would that be
create the world of the nightmare i am
your nightmare [ __ ] are you going into
people's dreams are you accepting
people's dreams
while they're sleeping
i wanna dicaprio is very i don't know
how to do his voice this is
just intense to have this like talking
squint
you're going into people's dreams you've
seen that meme right that that back and
forth between him and killian murphy and
the last panel is always
yeah this is like head turning in a
squid
mexican gold has been shouting out the
will smith cinematic universe the entire
time
yeah i think the you know it's it's it's
it's a hair away from being real
because you know so much of will smith
is in all those the kung fu master
universe that's what i wanted you know
what you could do with your will smith's
cinematic universe you could have the
will smith universe and then you could
have the depressing will smith universe
two different ones he doesn't play the
gray all right
will smith is either what you s what you
see from
like you know his men in blacks or hitch
or whatever hockey
or what you see in that jada pinkett
smith interview now what you said
there is the gray there that is right oh
my god it is
the gray of will smith is in that jada
picket interviewer he's cracking jokes
where you could tell he's [ __ ]
depressed
you can tell he wants to cry but then
you have in the movies you got his after
earth you got his seven pounds you got
his uh [ __ ] collateral suit of damage
happiness collateral beauty collateral
beauty lateral damage
crosso that's the cinematic universe
collateral movies crosstalk
i want a cinematic universe for every
movie that shares one word of a title
yeah
see what the movies of like american
something american
psych sniper american psycho american
sniper
american animals american crime
uh gee no no jeepers creep
no victor salva pedophile okay oh
welcome back erica don't apologize
you're great
a presidential cinematic universe 45 men
trying to save not just the us
but the world also grover cleveland has
a clone that's nice
i like that is that revealed in the
post-credits sequence that grover khalil
you know okay marcus is saying this in
the chat terminator versus predator
at this point
at this point with what has become with
the predator and terminator franchise
you might as well [ __ ] [ __ ] do it
right they've tried to reboot terminator
several times and even going so far as
to go this is the real part three
it didn't work so yeah [ __ ] it do
whatever they both had failed
part three essentially so that failed
yeah like this is the real sequel
so you might as well go all out and do a
terminator versus predator movie
i would be i think that could work
terminator and predator is the perfect
matchup
it would just be two people who just
can't figure out how to [ __ ] kill
each other
exactly exactly awesome it would be
great oh wait but arnold's been both of
them so it might be a little confusing i
just forgot who cares
it doesn't matter it does matter i care
about it
that would just sell the franchise even
more don't you realize you would have so
many arnold's
possibly on screen that's true or you
could have danny glover
you could have danny glover as a
terminator and really screw with
people's heads
yeah or you could tie it
you could tie it in where the t800s are
modeled after arnold schwarzenegger's
character and predator whose name i'm
forgetting right now yeah
i mean why wouldn't that's the movie
right there
[ __ ] like that's the perfect specimen
yeah
and and yeah you think of what predator
is all about it's about taking the most
you know formidable specimens holy
[ __ ] i gotta i gotta highlight this
comment right here
i i hope really quick i just got really
excited and i was like i gotta highlight
a comment
and you're like really quick i got a
thought to say what what is your thought
that is so important they couldn't wait
i just really appreciate we went off on
a tangent about marcos's comment
about terminator vs predator when he
clearly went on to say versus jingle all
the way
which that was worth interrupting which
i i would love to also see
how it was worth interrupting turbo man
belongs all right now
now all right colin in the chat is
saying a cursed
movie cinematic universe where a
paranormal detective
investigates a series of notoriously
cursed
movie productions like the exorcist
poltergeist etc i love it isn't that a
great idea
that is a great idea that is a fantastic
that could be the new conjuring
that could yeah literally yeah like you
don't have
a a historical forward character but
yeah
and you could i feel like people would
cut you some slack
on throwing in some narrative fictional
elements because you're dealing with
movies
so you could tie it like actually going
to the exorcist set
going to the set of like a twilight zone
those things you know
with the haunted sets that's actually a
really cool idea i would love to see
that yeah there's so much you can
you like you could do a lot and you
could even play with the mystery of
you could get uh very expressive with
you know imagining
what might have happened imagining the
mysteries that we still don't know but
also then doing some cool historical
exploration and stuff like that i think
that would be awesome
a square enix universe you know all
these video games
i i you should just do that people are
constantly pitching video game
franchises and it's like if you do the
nintendo cinematic universe that'd be
sweet
but i also think you can do that with
some other again i mean it won't always
work
i i don't think you can cross over
uncharted in the last
actually there's a way where you can
cross over and chart it in the last of
us now that i think about see that's my
main concern is i feel like that is like
universing via developer sounds like a
good idea but
but at least in my current you know
field of vision i feel like nintendo is
one of the few where their characters
are designed
in a way that makes a crossover there's
a cartoonishness to what they do that
makes it work whereas so many other
developers are focused on making the
most
realistic games so i feel like it would
be hard in a lot of ways
yeah exactly because you have these
universes that are so distinct that are
meant to be separate you know
i'm sorry richard bentley just so you
know i was i've been trying to find your
rap that you put down that you keep
saying it's horrible i've been wanting
to read it but i can't find it
i've been actually trying to find it
right now no richard bentley
but send it again for being here and
then let's read one more from the chat
here
um all right i see john wick
my god it's so hot in here is ac on i
don't
hear it i just heard the ac on it
because it's so hot
we put on all the lights that way it the
stream can look
better yeah and a little less delay now
we're dealing with a sweaty situation
right now
yes moral comment versus i'm gonna be
back in 30 seconds 30 seconds
jojo's bizarre adventure cinematic
universe would work just because there's
like so much [ __ ] in there that you
could spiral
off um
yu-gi-oh pokemon digimon i would love to
see pokemon and digimon just duke it out
for like you know
who really owns the turf
how we did that for an hour without
having
ac on it yeah i got it
all right i found more will smith a few
times
a supernatural one too ooh
ooh i got nothing
sometimes just saying ooh makes me think
i'll have something that comes into my
mind
a liam neeson universe i see like crash
bandicoot and spyro would cross over
well
and banjo kazooie there you go all right
guys
this is you guys bye hassam nice having
you here bye-bye
pre-dance john breaker greg got much
closer to being proficient at
everybody just thinks because we're
livestreaming
do something stupid which we have done i
will be robert pattinson's robin i'm
just not at liberty to speak about it
yet
all right guys who's next on the list we
got rory
nolan we rolling with rory nolan as he
hangs out with jason dolan dolan
cool colon colon
oh wait real quick i gotta go on a
little uh a little speech here
oh speech if you haven't seen the movie
palm springs on hulu if you have hulu
you can just watch it for free
well it's not free because you're paying
for hulu but if you haven't seen the
movie palm springs
watch it have you heard of this movie
it's andy sandberg movie right you know
what the genre is
no it's the most part it's a romantic
comedy
time loop movie oh cool and it is
[ __ ] great watch the last time it's
only like 80 minutes long it's short
nice it is [ __ ] inventive and it's a
fr
truly a fresh spin on uh time loop
movies so
um that was like a movie i watch my god
this is the first movie that has been
released
on a streaming service or on demand that
i really wish i saw in
theaters uh it is great if you haven't
seen palm springs it's on hulu
someone in patreon recommended it to me
earlier this week i was like i'm gonna
make some time this weekend
and then had some dinner last night put
it on palm springs it's really great
it really is snake pliskin and solid
snake join up that sounds
would that be fun anyway rory nolan rory
nolan
thank you looking kind of gory when i'm
hanging out with rory
now let's hear what the super chat is to
complete his story
filling in [ __ ] miranda
oh man come on get some rhymes
we ramen uh filling in the timeline
in john carpenter's apocalypse trilogy
the thing
prince of darkness and mouth of madness
mouth of madness is an hp lovecraft
inspired movie
um that would be cool yeah yeah john
carpenter i think has been wanting
has been wanting to cross over some of
his movies that would be cool
i would love to i i i would love at
least one more
likes true blue john carpenter joint
what i will say is john carpenter he
started halloween and i'm still
surprised in terms of crossover
discussion that we haven't i'm going to
highlight the names that we everyone
knows who which comment we're currently
on
um god damn it god dammit
john do it all right so um with
halloween i'm still surprised we haven't
gotten like
anything further beyond a freddy versus
jason
because it's like whoa what about having
all the excitement like freddie versus
jason versus michael myers
freddie versus jason versus ash i don't
think michael works
because michael is always serious
whereas like
jason no jason movies get silly and so
do freddy movies and chucky movies
michael's
face serious have you seen the curse of
michael myers but
but as a as a character michael has
absolutely no humor
like and those movies what about [ __ ]
esther rhymes being like
happy halloween [ __ ] and may you
never
ever rest in peace jason doesn't have a
sense of humor
but the movies like after part two
definitely do whereas michael movies
get campy and sometimes bad but i
i've never seen one where i'm like the
goal of this was to be tongue-in-cheek
whereas every slasher practically other
than that one devolves into that
fine i was just trying to add
to rory's comments super chat worth it
[ __ ]
i'm sorry don't take it back
michael belongs he's the silliest one my
hair started off
fine at the top of the stream her hair
looks and now that i've been sweating
like it's hot in here a little bit
it still looks it's gotten oh it's gonna
get just like weirdly puffy and flat up
here that's the way it's gonna go for
the rest of the stream
i i like heads up uh-huh oh yeah why the
[ __ ] we haven't said it mcu and dc
crossover why have we got in there yeah
yeah gabriel hold on gabriel 9 tm
we gave us rap names just now yours is
lil grega
and mine is hair long
well you're a much cooler one than me
but you get to be lil
okay all right yo we got a breach it's
time to shout out mark
leach because he's a real peach put the
raps to a screech i beseech you to
listen
because we're gonna hang out in the park
with marcus who ride our nova's ark and
he's gonna hang out with tony stark
yep shark jason clark
thanks mark leach sevens comic
characters cap america lucas lee scott
pilgrim jensen from losers and human
torch
fight crime together love you guys you
know i appreciate you bringing up this
comment
because there was so lo whatever it was
like captain america discussion would be
like but he was also do you know did you
know
he was also fantastic you know
but everywhere but he's done so many
comic book characters
like so many yeah he's a staple of comic
book
him and jamon hansu is and one's just a
little bit more famous than the other
hair they're both part of the mcu
multiple times
but yeah i think yeah jimon hansu has
done so many comic book movies
so many uh the king's been franchised
now
aquaman shazam guardians of the galaxy
constantine amistad
[Laughter]
i love that graphic novel really great
stuff based on true events and then
and then chris evans has done all these
movies that [ __ ] mark leach just
listed here
i think it would he's done so many so
many and yeah
that'd be fun is snow piercer based on a
graphic novel snow piercer
the fun thing though is that with the
chris evans characters
i mean a few of them have a sense of
humor but they're very they are
different they are
distinguished from one another each one
of his comic book characters so it would
be fun to watch them crossover
the only one i don't know well is is
jensen from the losers but the rest of
these characters yeah i'm like they're
all different personalities
all right okay oh oh we got some super
chats that came in
would you look at this we got a
beautiful bliss
okay we ran bliss a lot last time so
okay let's run beautiful
feeling kind of whimsical as i'm
thinking about how beautiful bliss
can be but you can't take this too
literal cause our rhymes can sound
cynical
but at the end of the day miss bliss
you're always quite beautiful
oh we did it okay john add on yeah add
on john
and dude and dutiful in the way that you
ask us
a question to answer journey in juman
thank you
journey and jumanji cross over a bit
better what is
oh journey to the center of the earth
that would be cool that's a great one
especially because dwayne johnson saved
both of those franchises
oh yeah yeah journey to really needed
really needed it and it and it clearly
was a success that he did that
yeah that's why they're making so many
more money more journeys too
so many more i feel like you could make
the rock cinematic universe if you
wanted to now you could just call it the
rock
yeah because he's always the same guy
he's called rocking universe man
yes right dude it'd be great new year's
rock and ever
go for it john rhyme grey poupon with
niraj krishna oh
wait i got all day so does niraj
he ain't gonna disappear not like a
mirage he's concrete and on
beat thank you for your super chat how
about a robin hood and a king arthur
universe
i'm surprised this has not happened
because those are public domain
characters
who get a new reboot every five years
based on whatever the current zeitgeist
to film styles is
that's a great call niraj yeah have you
thought about that before it seemed like
you that really sparked a thought for
you
no i'm just no i feel like i should have
i was like this sounds
odd like not obvious as to like downplay
but it sounds like a very
natural thing to want to do is to you
know especially with the way
i mean you know the latest robin hood
movie was like the batman begins so
they're
seriously comic booking this stuff and
so yeah it would be perfect to cross
those two over
very good job you know very good i am a
fan niraj
of this pitch thank you right
right write it too because you could
just sell that and you don't have to
worry about that right
so that's such a good point yeah you
might you don't even need to like
set up a cinematic universe just [ __ ]
do one movie and cross them over yeah
at this point there's been a gazillion
of those movies yeah
and then [ __ ] cross them over in one
movie yeah and then you can introduce
however many nights however many of them
oh my god i just just [ __ ] do it with
terran eggs and and goddamn
uh pretty boy uh
no the other guy [ __ ] what's his
goddamn name the pacific rim sons of
anarchy guy
charlie hunnam charlie yeah there you go
oh okay of course yeah who was arthur
yeah
the beloved adaptation by guy ritchie
all right anissa denise is back
all right john i rhymed a lot of anissa
before and i gotta admit that was easily
my best rhyming shout out so far
anisa stand up straight ain't no tower
of pisa
oliva ain't gonna leave ya
in the dust not to rust
no crust on that bread
that you've generously tipped for us
thank you for the contribution thanks
denise
anisa says trolls john wick crossover
the best
oh [ __ ] ever
i feel like trolls continental dude um
john wick crossover i really
think i really do think
i don't really dive into conspiracies
but i think there i have a conspiracy
theory about a connection with john wick
and matrix four
i really think they're going to be
trying to tie it in because originally
before all this you know coveted [ __ ]
they were gonna talk never they weren't
gonna tie it in but they were gonna
release
matrix four and john wick 4 in the same
exact day
and you see the set photos are keanu
reeves and i thought they were going to
neo him up
at least for bill and ted 3. they shaved
his beard so it just looks [ __ ]
bizarre but
they at least they shaved his beard
gummy shaves now he looks like he
just [ __ ] just now um
but in this and the john in the in the
set photos from matrix 40 looks like
straight out of
john wick not just keanu with a beard he
looks like he's in a john wick movie
i can't tell and i can't tell if that's
like the the look he's had to maintain
because they've made the john wick so
close together or if that's just his
chosen this is my look now
and with the fact that they have the the
guy who plays the key maker from the
matrix reloaded in john wick 3 they have
lawrence fishburne in there
um they got this gunfu style with john
wick
i could see some weird thing that they
do to tie it in
how how mind-blowing would it be if they
released the matrix four
only to then retcon all the john wicks
into their own universe
oh that'd be sad what a weird thing that
would do another kind of undercut
a lot of things i'm like yeah what what
would that do to the legacy of both
would it like
hyper charge it or weirdly deflate right
right
yeah oh i see uh sorry we're not we're
not back yet are we back are we going
back
okay we'll do one more one or two more
okay
how behind are we what what time did
what did uh
505. we're only 40 minutes behind that's
pretty good
unless we're usually one hour behind
we're 38 minutes behind
marcos amaya hiya marcos amaya
i'm uh gonna read your question yo
i'd be watching on netflix narcos and i
hang out with my boy marcos
and he's hanging out with trump at the
largo
yeah boom and what's his last name
oh amaya amaya and
okay all right marco samaya rhyming with
greg alba because that's what i do with
last names that end in amaya
yeah he stole from jaby kowai her name
be achara
and sometimes he'd be hitting on a nissa
boom
with amaya and i i say
fill me up with your saliva what do you
say
pat in oswald star wars marvel universe
parks and rec
what the [ __ ] are you talking about pat
and oswalt's
star wars marvel universe parks and rec
i don't know anything about this
i don't i mean that sounds like
something that would come out of his uh
like stand up or something
okay wait a minute let's do this star
wars and marvel could cross over
yeah at this point they easily could
cross over with how cosmic marvel has
gone but kevin feige he's a control
freak according to cosmicbook.news
the most reliable source according to
all our commentators people
love it love it when we cover cosmic
book dot news and dr doom [ __ ] they love
especially
tyrone doesn't get anywhere near as much
hate if we cover the same [ __ ]
article he does
doesn't make sense so sometimes i'll
notice like hey tyrone covered this too
why is no one hating
as much on this as they are on us okay
so after a small amount of research this
is an episode i haven't seen where
patton oswalt plays a character who
filibusters over the idea of a star wars
marvel crossover so yeah basically take
his idea from that episode of parks and
rec and make it real well i appreciate
the super chat there buddy um but
i don't but the thing would start whoa
john what the
[ __ ] i'm just adding some humor all
right on the internet be smarter would
you
thank you so much please it's gonna be
so much easier to cancel you than anyone
else the money
thank you all right thank you for your
contribution that i don't deserve
and i'm gonna go out and i'm going to
whip myself after this because i'm a
white guy
all right pat and oswald star wars okay
star wars and marvel i feel like are
destined to cross over one day don't you
think
when they're both desperate when marvel
needs it it'll happen
because right now i feel like marvel is
in a much better place than star wars is
overall so uh
you know jason dolan's a sincere friend
of ours
who like i've been who i will hang out
with when he's back in california all
the time and he literally texted me
during the stream saying
you should 100 react to pattern oswalt's
park and wreck star wars marvel reboot
idea
so marcus you're on to something thanks
jason for texting me in the stream
thanks buddy only you and my brother and
olivia are the
i'll only three text message from yeah
all right
one more here sylvester freisen
jr fast and furious meets transformers
my first episode of movie fights when i
sucked balls at movie fights
that was my pitch fast and furious and
transformers
they should totally collide don't know
why they haven't tried setting up
they're both owned by universal
right no no transfer is paramount it is
okay yeah never mind oh yeah yeah but
fast and furious and transformers would
totally work
totally and then i think michael bay
directing a
fast and furious movie would totally
work just on its own actually i think
that would yeah
that or or what if he directed like the
next hobson shot like what if he did the
next spin-off because i don't i think
his uh sensibility would trample all
over whatever vin diesel wants to do
with this movie yes
uh i'm feeling lesser when i talk with
sylvester
have you seen my friend nestor last name
be
fryson and he'd be wanting sucking on my
johnson
sucking hard like a dyson oh
while he boxes with mike tyson boom oh
fryson
that works really well yeah anyway
thanks sylvester fryson all right
let's see what you guys are saying in
the chat let's see what the chat we got
a couple of what you guys are saying in
the chat someone wants someone
we're gonna go to our stream labs
afterwards someone wants to no
i'm sorry john i lost it go off your
memory since you're the
movie trivia showdown king of all time
that's right well i remember how much
you liked castlevania
and i saw somebody say that they wanted
to cross
uh castlevania over with the room
because maybe johnny is vampire
yeah that'd be great um also i saw one
with an assassin movie universe john
wick
martin blank was just happy to see some
gross point blank love
jules from pulp fiction mr mrs smith oh
grace
birds of prey versus grace randolph no
no no no
you throw birds of prey and they're
being led by jessica chastain oh
then we got a movie yeah yeah grace
randall i love that
uh horror heroes the uh mccready from
the things
this would this this is like uh except
for sydney prescott this is the
john carpenter horror heroes oh wait a
minute wait
okay wait a minute where are we talking
john wick someone just said it uh
uh oh sylvester's saying james bond
versus the equalizer better yet
james bond versus jason bourne that
needs to happen
that definitely that desperately needs
to happen
but who would win who would win jason
bourne with john wick that would be the
best ending
because you can't have jameson born or
should build up to this fight
and then john wait just shut down john
wick's just two headshots
i'm trying to get the [ __ ] away what are
you guys doing what are you doing in my
way yeah yeah yeah
and i mean there's an inconvenience in
the middle of him being on the run
and i think people would be okay with it
because right now at least john wick
tracks the best of those three of course
he does man
people love keon and somebody else
pitched i i forget who but somebody
pitched a key on new universe we're
also i mean somebody else else else said
uh
like a bill and ted won and i think that
would actually work
oh ethan abraham in the chat is saying
hitchcock's cinematic universe
oh my god that was so where they should
just do it awful places
like what they tried doing with league
of extraordinary gentlemen yeah they
should do that
and get like kenneth branagh to direct
him
because i am not a fan of the way he
directs his movies
generally speaking i've i've heard it
said that there is a very very very
different
uh persona behind the camera between
shakespeare
kenny b and everything else can you be
oh
in the chat doom patrol versus strength
i've heard someone mention
i can't i'm sorry i can't find your name
right now i heard someone mention
um the boys versus doom patrol
and i recently started up doom patrol
and i recently started
what are you gonna watch do patrol john
i recently started up doom patrol and
um i think yeah with them versing the
boy
i'm only on episode four right now
though and i think that versus and the
boys that'd be that'd be really fun i
think if you take
the boys not not the superheroes part of
the seven
within the boys the actual the boys yeah
versing the dude patrol that would be a
really fun time
especially that kind of level of
vulgarity and such also i saw umbrella
academy
[ __ ] great show ooh gerard way
whatever [ __ ] great [ __ ] they're
doing
brother academy they can't get it my
hero academia versus demon slayer
the heroes would win i like demon slayer
but but the heroes of my hero academia
just have like crazy more power
have you seen a midoriya fight versus a
donjero fight yeah that'd be fun
uh hi spider dark welcome to the chat
someone really wants a real rejects
collab with dwayne and jazz
oh my god i would love that i've seen
that shouted out here several times
i would i would hit on
dwayne so much yeah yeah definitely
oh there's a new hashtag starting for me
to watch doom patrol yeah john watch
doom patrol what the [ __ ]
every time i open my twitter now it's
just going to be a new list of shows i
need to
yeah you should catch up on uh let's but
all right unbreakable split glass meets
life is strange that'd be fun
um okay gabriel i got a knowledge all
three spider-man in one movie
when is the sony cinematic whatever the
spunk
release the spump cut yeah when are they
going to cross them over
we need i really want that to happen all
three of them
that really needs to happen yeah as does
this i think toby maguire is sad right
now
oh sad toby he has not been around in a
hotbed all right guys i miss him
let's let's do this together scooby-doo
meets ghostbusters and supernatural
i'm gonna just type in toby mcguire
today
on google that needs to be a blog let's
see what pops up for toby mcguire it's
got a picture of tobey maguire for every
day of the year let's go to the news
section
nothing he's just disappeared all right
never mind the third
birthday was not was just a few topher
grace's birthday was a few days you
never mind
wow stealing toby's thunder away from
his hey
a religion cinematic universe religion
cinematic universe yeah
with all the different deities oh that
would be so non-controversial
everyone would get on board you would be
able to depict half of those creatures
without people you know
you could do the bible cinematics
you could do a bible cinematic universe
you could
there's so many different characters but
you should go there
hollywood i won't do it if you're
listening hollywood
well you know get like you and now
imagine the entertainment weekly
centerfold where it's like oh we got uh
we got uh
who's the guy who directed mother we got
him darren aaron aronofsky we got
mel gibson you remember you're hardly
but you can't remember
darren well when was the last time he
made a movie oh mother
has he made a movie since then yeah
what is it i don't know you're the movie
trivia king
you almost beat mike kalinowski and i
sucked against the barbarian don't give
me that you know what
everyone's going to remember your match
though and i'm bitter now because of
other people
that's okay and i blame you because who
else am i going to blame that's true i'm
the only person here
[Laughter]
a process of elimination uh john am i
set up properly
are we are we current uh we got fled we
did eric
and okay so we got we
we yeah achara come on bernie i mean
john
no dolan okay second we go down we keep
going down actually we're kind of
man now we keep on going down oh [ __ ]
oh we got some super we got some
streamlabs we've got some hella
streamlabs
i did not realize that so we got uh
hitman hudson with hamilton and we did
that one and then we got the uk
the tim roth one was the one okay so we
got this this question here at the top
for jason who has messaged me
ain't no choice
thanks jason all right sending me dick
pics oh i love
jason's dick pics tim roth's character
in the hateful eight
is the great great grandfather of
michael fossbender's character in
inglorious bastards
is that true is that some thing
tarantino said
are you are you literally just laying
down a piece that sounds like something
tarantino would say in some weird radio
interview i could see it happening i
mean it's
exactly the kind of thing he would say
that's a hundred percent
yeah you would say that i'm like and now
i can't dispute it i'm like it must be
true
yeah that sounds 100 true it has to be
true
well thank you jason thanks dolan let us
know if that's real info or if you're
just pitching a hypothetical
okay sack it can't hack it as she plays
ratchet and clank it call sheriff
bracket
she's got this wonderful tactic for us
to read off from kate sackett
on this stream lad super chatted
creaking like a mattress
thank you a revisit to question greg
asked
last john can you read it please a
revisit to a question greg
asked last stream when i mentioned
finishing last of us two
sat with it for a week now and must say
any game that can cause me that emotion
that can cause that
uh that many emotions and take a risk
should be commended overall i loved it
as a sequel
katie's case sack i keep some of your
names katie okay
second appreciate that appreciate your
your chat and yeah
i mean you got to give it to like
sometimes the sequel might
be so divisive or even upsetting but if
you find yourself
ruminating on it for a while you got to
give it some credit
i think some of the most striking
especially movies but even games and
stuff like that are the ones that put
you in a place where at first you're
like
maybe a little upset you've got a lot to
chew on but the more you think about it
the more it settles in and the more the
pieces start to coalesce in your mind
exactly i mean because think about it
like this
one movie that is starting its own
cinematic universe pirates of the
caribbean
that happened with me with pirates too
um
i love pirates one saw it countless
times before the sequel came out
too many and then i watched pirates 2
and i did not like it
i really hated it and then a few days
had gone by
and i was just thinking about it like
all the time for some reason
and then it just hit me of
i think i'm beginning to get this just
from thinking about it i get it
i think i get it i think i love this
movie
and then i watched it again in the
videos i was like
this movie is awesome and so
and it's so dick it's so dark and much
more moody and more
like horror-based and it's fantastical
elements
um so yeah my last of us too was pirates
of the caribbean
dead man's chest just as good just
as quality that was mine just as high
caliber i appreciate that case sackett
oh we got another dolan in here danny
glover would be eddie murphy
mel gibson go danny glover will be the
eddie murphy mel gibson go between
i love that you know what as much as
i've been a defender of mel gibson
i'm i'm really dialing that back now
these days um
so i shouldn't get you there well i've
what t-shirt of his face saying i'm with
mel
yeah sure okay i'll still wear it in
private
you know at the end of the movie uh what
was that
silence yeah the end when with the
crucifix
everywhere every shirt i'll have
underneath is your mel gibson shirt
i just imagined you in a position where
there someone's forcing you you gotta
step on mel's face
you gotta step on this picture of mel
you gotta step on it just to prove
that you're not faithful you're funnier
if more people have seen silence
i think that's an underrated scorsese um
yeah
um because there's this interview
circulating
around the time of like hey do you like
mel hey
when they asked celebrities if like
another celebrity's opinion makes the
biggest [ __ ] difference in the world
well they know they know celebrity life
so they can tell us
who to like right so there was um so
they interviewed
um uh uh murtaugh
danny glover danny devito they
interviewed danny glover
because he's worked with mel a few times
now right four times to be exact
and they're like so do you what do you
think about mel gibson's recent comments
and he just kept saying look mel is a
real friend of mine he's a real friend
he's a real friend that's all he kept
saying he just kept hammering it down
so that opened up the door for everyone
to be like melanie racist
because danny glover said it and
uh i've been an anime i've been a guy
who's been i love mel
but i think he's got some issues he's
got to work out
in the meantime i'll watch his movies in
private without anyone knowing
well yeah everyone knows because i'm
constantly vocalizing it
well i mean there are a lot of ways to
discuss the conversation of art and
artists but
as much as i don't like piracy if you
know you
you morally disagree with somebody and
you don't want to support them but
you're still curious about what the
thing is you could always just watch it
yeah non-monetarily richard bentley i'm
seeing your comments in the chat i'm
glad to have you be a part of this as
well
um okay oh bernie alvarado
going down to eat some avocados
goes down to the drive of rodeo
and he gonna give me some
joe blow movie trellos bernie
competing in attorney have you carried
out
on a gurney thank you
for your bert and ernie
thank you for yours i was gonna call it
super chat but that would be us
streamlabs
happy madison cinematic universe a bunch
of adam sandler characters in one movie
and then we can finally once and for all
see if any of them are
actually different from each adam sham
the adam sandler voice that he does my
mind will always go oh i can't do that
right now i can't hear it and all i got
to do is do a bad version and then i'm
like oh that's how you do it
it's not a good voice really the easiest
oh that'd be very annoying they're all
on netflix
sec attack kyle's back at it
uh thank you for again for uh
contributing as
and living in denial can't get out of my
mind
kyle i treat him like my own child oh
don't let
kyle spit out all that bile you wanna
rap battle him across the lines of eight
mile
well he rocks all that crazy ass hair
style
spilling your brains all over the tile
anyway as for
an insane crossover i'll take greg's
mario kart movie
john's all car movie universe and throw
in wacky races
yeah why not throw it in oh dude that'd
be [ __ ] crazy man
i actually think a mario kart i think if
you did a nintendo cinematic universe
you could combine like some weird trippy
ass
dream hallucination [ __ ] and and do
all the crossover movies in one dude you
could
call your super smash brothers movie or
let's just say that's a temporary title
but you can have this the super smash
brothers thing you're leading up to at
the end with the big boss battle
but you could have some weird dream
sequence for like some hallucination
they were
they're forced to race each other or
they're forced to do like games at a
mario party or something dude you can do
that why not
yeah [ __ ] nintendo cinematic universe
just make it
cube with the nintendo characters
flev doran oh thank you thank you kyle
sackett
oh i don't know wait yeah that's it
thank you thank you kyle
and phleb thank you again
flev i gotta start watching devs a lot
of people
oh what is my animal planet episode on
oh my god is it on today oh it's so is
ah chappie goes to district nine that's
the one i want
dude you're famous now you're on point
you're on tv
babe we're all on animal planet
we're on animal planet hooray we're on
animal
nine o'clock nine o'clock pacific that
means the
that means the east coasters already be
watching it
yeah i like it
chappie goes to district nine where's
watson at get him in here watson
cinematic universe this is the post
effect
hi watt spots all this is the
post-effect
watson star of my cat from hell come
here little buddy oh
watson's my buddy oh i had to uh make
sure to bring him back in case he
attacked me and then i ruined the whole
show
just how much it paid off who just
who said that shouts out to isaac being
like
who said his on animal planet um
i'm not gonna watch that episode i will
but go watch it i'm going to react to it
on patreon
yeah what an animal planet blocker i
would love for that i would
love to be in this position my god i
react to that episode
copyright strikes i'm in the [ __ ]
episode i mean most of the goddamn
episode
yeah and you're my home they shot this
thing
sorry you don't have the legal rights to
show any of this
we're going to take your channel down
now
you got three strikes
that's that's how i hear youtube claims
in my head hey did the
real rejects across the line yeah
the normies i think uh youtube contacted
them did they not
have
uh eric's back in the station
eric thank you eric horseman eric was
here with the beer making it clear
that he wants to hear our opinions and
our thoughts
on a mashup lol of dune stargate
starship troopers and the last
starfighter
i think we should do that before dune
comes out
because then it would a raise the hype
for dune
but also if they could get their dune
[ __ ] right in this movie before the
actual dune movie gets it right i think
that would be very funny
yeah but yes actually that would be
great
yeah that's a great idea dune stargate
starship troopers and the last
starfighter all crossing over
it would make sense there's not that
much to peel back i would love to just
see comic locklin
and kurt russell in the same movie oh
yes i agree call david lynch
yeah be awesome olivia can you come in
here
olivia's getting hair compliments people
want to see you
people want your presence she can't hear
me she's yelling you [ __ ] [ __ ]
at ghost of tsushima right now
whenever she starts a new game my
experience is i'm editing and then i
just hear her
yelling at the tv every 30 to 60 minutes
that's what it is fleva's b-a-c-k
honestly i don't have a great idea i
decided tonight to stay up
late and watch live but i don't have
nothing good to bring to the discussion
flev that right there is bringing plenty
to the discussion right your presence
and
support and love john ryan flev flev
i gotta start watching devs um
my best friend is greg
and we used to know this guy named kev
in
herrera and a guy named ian guerra
we lost 15 viewers and now i'm just
naming people none of you know i know my
rhymes are
because they weren't ready for the bars
they couldn't handle the heat you know
it's not the rhymes that are the
problems it's just the bars couldn't
handle what i was delivering yeah people
must be [ __ ]
because if you can't handle like the
eighth time i've tried to rhyme flev
i don't know what this animal planet
situation i'm not even planning on
watching the episode
but um but the i'm really not i i was
just cringe the whole time
uh but yeah apparently i think it's
supposed to air today i totally forgot
about that until someone said it post it
on the community page
get some views for animals yeah it's
gonna totally boost the channel
let's see yeah we're on animal planet in
hopes of getting subscribers to watch
our reaction channel
hey you never know someone might i am
going to be
looking now we can get one person to be
like to comment
i'm just saying who else here off
animals want one person to just be like
saw you on animal planet loved you now
i'm gonna subscribe
lifelong subscriber buddy this ain't the
same kind of content but all right
thanks man watch me train my cats eric
was here to hold dear keeping it clear
all right oh eric thank you buddy thank
you so much don't break your wallet
today buddy
the shakespearean cinematic universe
first
movie macbeth versus othello wherein
lady macbeth
kills desdemona she was kinda
or she kind of wanted to die anyway
framing macbeth and othello is out for
revenge
damn that would be heavy that would
recontextualize a lot of things but uh i
would be down at this point
especially if you wrote it in iambic
pentameter you gotta make
a a [ __ ] shakespearean like cheesy
ass
one-off movie like who directed abraham
lincoln vampire hunter
timur beckmambatov that wow
and you couldn't recall daryanovsky yep
i know timor bek mambatov
who is the uh luke bisson of this
generation
that's what i mean you need a director
like him to do some like
just cheesy ass shakespearean action
movies
yes yes i want it i'm surprised it
hasn't happened
thank you thank you eric for that uh
country that's a hilarious one right
there
actually i think he's been kind of
serious that'd be cool that would be
cool thanks dude i would still be down
and you know who else is down this chill
level tv
hit you with the pipe like pvc take it
on
tv like rca get out of my way
we could take it one word at a time you
know
you don't want to go out there and kill
you want to behave so
chill otherwise you'll go down to the
level of the devil
and then you're going to feel this
malevolent spirits when
just if you need a chill level why don't
you just turn on the tv
chill out in your tp as i watch eric
cryptkeys the boys
are supernatural on my television
on my zenith tv i need my girlfriend
here
uh what are you saying thanks chill
level hold our rejects
just got here 54 minutes into the stream
maybe someone has already mentioned this
but here's my pitch a cinematic universe
oh what a great idea with the simpsons
family guy bob's burgers
king of the hill rick and morty beasts
and butt head
south park american dad
uh bojack horseman solar opposites
dude f family fun
yeah why not be fun why not every new
viewer that's here is from animal planet
tv right now
you're watching me on my camera that's
gonna blow up the channel i'm telling
you
this guy has a youtube channel we gotta
sign on oh goodness gracious that'd be
great i mean the simpsons already did
their family guy
crossover but that would actually be
well on all three at least simpsons
family guy and king of the hill have all
acknowledged each other in universe and
american dad
has uh what was there was a great i
don't remember if it was in the
crossover but there was one episode
where
stewie confronts um
what's what's the dad's name on american
dad stan
that's stan stan i thought the kid was
stan
steve oh okay yeah there's yours i
confront stan
and he goes uh oh my i'm forgetting
everyone's name on this show uh family
guy
uh paraplegic joe joe joe and then like
uh stan held has his gun held up but
stewie and he goes not now joe and he
goes what my name's stan
oh not bad so yeah i i think the doors
that would work that would be really
funny yeah okay
oh and you know what too oh sorry what
are you gonna say i don't know
uh the they've they have i keep hoping
against all hope that
they've just signed a a big new deal
with mike judge
for comedy central to bring back beavis
and buddha so half of me is sitting here
thinking like
if they could bring back like a king of
the hill or like just the more
stuff that gets resurrected the more
stuff will get resurrected sure
so like now is a time where i feel like
is american dance still on
yeah i feel like what they do is kind of
sort of suited to our time somewhat i
feel like king of the hill is like
really suited to the now so like i'd
love to see some of this stuff come back
or cross over whatever you like uh we
got
mimi oh sometimes we rhyme deliriously
for mimi who thinks we can behave a
little bit creepy but we go all
freestyling out all wildly
mimi sitting listening to fettuccine
big fan of freddy gibbs
uh mimi says
thanks mimi thank you bad and evil
characters crossing over with the good
place where the characters die on their
show and wake up
in the good place like mazzykin from
lucifer
beth from good girls frank from
shameless etcetera to see if they can
redeem their characters
not a bad idea that's a great idea that
would be
very fun plus you get ted danson
speaking of lucifer i just started that
too
speaking of lucifer i just pledged my
ever lucifer i just sold my soul to the
devil
and i said now i'm on animal planet
i went on there to perform ritual
sacrifice because that's what the devil
likes
the show's already out doesn't matter
what i say
but i sold it for it i get on animal
planet
because it's hard i would love for
people to watch that show ending
my camera melt then come over here and
be like this is what this guy does on
his youtube channel
what the [ __ ] wow jesus coming to the
mcu
oh god all right hey let's go back to
these comments
because someone said trolls and ants
uh i gotta say ands and a bug's life
should cross over that should happen
definitely i see one here uh tomb raider
meets uncharted would be cool
nah i'm surprised they haven't done it
since they've ape their franchise in a
lot of way
iv arcanet granada says santa clarita
diet means
dexter santa clarita diet means
dexter you know what i've wanted to see
that that reminded me ivy
reminding me iv of this idea that i once
had that made me feel
lively then i want to see anyway sorry
uh
it was text i wanted to do a graphic
novel of
dex uh dexter and um walter white
going toe-to-toe because it's more
psychological yeah and there could be
some like
thing where uh walter white had to do
drug deal thing in [ __ ] miami florida
or some [ __ ] you know
that would have been cool that would
have been cool olivia's dad's going to
watch
olivia your best feature you're saying
the chat your best features your hair
it's not uh it's right here oh
body rot scooby doo
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's true but you can't cancel
scooby-doo on epstein island which is
exactly what i want
oh god small soldiers versus puppet
master that actually makes some sense
uh let's see here let's see here okay
thundercats we're trying to fill the
world silence we're looking for the
comments thundercats versus thor would
be fun jim
john's watching me on my cat from hell
this is why i went live just so people
could chime in
i totally forgot this was coming out
so it's on at 9 00 pm here apparently
okay let me just tell you it's on 9 p.m
here so we got east coasters watching so
east coast no they're watching on
midnight that's when that
yeah i stayed up for this
i stayed up i made sure i drank coffee
at 9 00 p.m i was like i had no way of
passing out for that half hour of
entertainment
a hancock cinematic universe would
probably work yeah
we should start with the sequel yeah
yeah we should start building it beyond
one film
yeah oh deshawn no that's where you saw
that okay yeah
john deserves better in the showdown
what do you mean
i deserve john's bringing nothing but
praise for that one performance he did
many years ago and it's
no matter what john does that's that's
the beautiful thing about it you should
embrace it dude
you could get like uncomfortable you
could get like one question right out of
like a billion questions in a match
yeah and it would be like ah tough game
for john but that free-for-all
it's always your saving grace that's a
beautiful thing it is but now i'm i feel
weird because i haven't lived back up to
it
for me yeah for me they go nah tough
game greg
but that time you pissed your pants on
stage was funny
which reputation would you rather have
unfair
that's fair fair enough
i liked lucifer mimi in the chats asking
i liked it
i was expecting something that was a
little bit more along the lines of
something that's more akin to
supernatural per se and honestly i had
no idea what to expect
the show's very corny very cheesy and
maybe again it's like startling
work yeah and so i was kind of taken
aback by how
it felt so much like network television
how does it feel
if you're watching it through the scope
of like oh this is a new fox tv show
well i just finished all the gotham
which is pretty [ __ ] like
fox tv that's very cheesy but also very
edgy and and then this show was
just like very like the most networky
adaptation i could imagine for this
concept really
and uh i really enjoy the lead character
all the performances are fine and the
lead character i thought was fun
i was into it but i found myself not
thinking about it until you asked me
this question just until
lucifer was brought up in this chat so
right now my attention is more focused
on on
making my way through doom but it's kind
of hard to be watching like umbrella
academy and doom patrol
two very r-rated
shows that are designed for streaming
and then suddenly i'm like oh lucifer
yeah that's all right you know
oh cartoon network versus nickelodeon
cinematic universe and that
that sounds like a thing that'd be great
oh okay how much like a video game that
you have
we got to wrap up in the next 30 to 40
minutes true that
i'm trying to be realistic with this
expectation this time yes
okay so um
uh but so yeah i want to make sure that
we're not
far behind here on the super chats what
time is that we're
5 10. so an hour and ten why does this
always happen
all right i box all right so now the
wraps gotta get more compact only two
bars each
all right what is this ibox at night 23
and me getting my genetics
tested okay look at this at night when i
play do we [ __ ]
so tight and i rocks at your light
and what happened when i fight i think
well i lost it john what is it
the acai uh the acu anime cinematic
universe
in today's climate that'll bring the big
bucks
no doubt um yes if it were if they did
it as animals
whoa whoa hold on a sec okay if you're
gonna do an anime cinematic universe
let's first figure out how to [ __ ] to do
a proper anime annotation
and then we can think about a cinematic
universe
yeah the only way a cinematic universe
works is if you do it in animation and
not live action
yeah because yeah that that genre of
adaptations has a long way to go
i mean that i think an anime cinematic
universe is like we've mentioned it many
times in the last two hours
the animated cinematic universe is
something that needs to happen
or just [ __ ] a proper good anime
movie is something needs to happen too
i'll start there i think that's where we
should start yeah decent anime film
i've heard that lucifer does get better
i'm seeing that in the chats don't worry
i'll i will continue it
knowing me i will continue it we got
eric horseman
who who goes around from streamlabs to
super chats you gotta love that about
the game i do i do love it about the guy
a clive barker universe would give me a
orgasm
i think that would be great i mean clive
barker has
of all the like americans yeah of all
the uh
tour yeah thank you yeah thanks for the
super chat man yeah
holy [ __ ] you're generous thanks man
yeah hell yeah but uh you know of the uh
prolific purveyors of classic you know
80s
horror films and 90s horror films and
stuff i feel like clive barker
is one who has a certain element of like
mythological lore to his work that
that permeates there i don't know how to
how to separate but there's something
very gothic about all of clive barker
that i've ever been exposed to that i
think would lend itself to a universe
more so than
say the works of a west craven or
something like that you know
i think horror cinematic universes are
tough because
you need horror movies to be scary and
there's something about a cinematic
universe that just automatically doesn't
makes it feel like it's not scary
because the thing is
clashes and excitement and action scenes
where you kind of associate with
cinematic universes
well yeah to make a good horror
cinematic universe i think you would
have to make it so that the scary part
is
is more the world itself rules of the
universe and not
you know yeah a particular character or
something like that so it wouldn't just
be like
the lead set up a pinhead you know
whatever people call them
but you know it'll be great the office
and parks and recreation
i am surprised that i'm surprised they
never did it considering they're similar
people
cast and cr and worked on it together
there's nothing precluding
them from occupying the same universe
it's actually pretty surprising that
they haven't done that i'm i'm
unless i'm totally missing something i'm
pretty surprised
they don't exist is there a zoom special
i think it's because
um who's who's uh what's her name the
the girl from i love you man
and uh rashida rashida jones
well she's got a sister that's how you
would explain that away yeah yeah oh
yeah cause rashida jones is in
uh she's in the office and she's in
parks and rec so i think that's why they
haven't
attempted it you could just say that
she's in witness protection but that
isn't a bad idea eric horseman
john would especially love that i would
nancy
my sweet nan
[Laughter]
sorry i have to say that every time your
name pops up my favorite pokemon is
chansey but you can't
do better than to catch them all unless
you're catching nancy
and i'm so fancy you already know oh man
fancy works yeah i don't know why i
would reach all the way to the depths of
pokemon for that one
nancy keeping it fancy sneaking around
like
tom clancy like the pony prancy
yeah all right knives out but not
but knives i know like i my eyes are so
blurry
knives outs benoit blanc uh and the
conjuring cinematic universe
also glad to finally be able to catch
you all live again glad to have you
here with us live nancy that's nice i
would love to see benoit blanc
investigate spooky [ __ ]
i would really undercut the horror
donut hole this ghost is like an eclair
oh john bring the accent back that's
right i'm going to bring my draw back
into the
bring it back john especially since
nancy you've missed a couple of our
streams in the past
you can't be missing out on this
southern draw yeah
the only accent i won't be uh you know
via mentally slapped over
um i i i think uh oh man there's so many
great comments in here about
crossovers that i'm just seeing here
like sega and such i'm loving it
yes i was in it's always sunny
philadelphia and i'm in my cat from hell
and both of these crossovers
my sunny cat from hell
[Laughter]
david gandy david gandy sweet like
candy look around man he's a dandy
i would love to give him a hug i'll
never call him a namby pam because he
could kick my ass with tae kwon do
insanity
that was genuinely good john
a broken clock man right twice a day
genuinely good it only took
55 shout outs to get here i've been
listening
to a lot damn john that was good thanks
man i've been listening to a lot of wow
a lot of clipping albums in the last
couple of days hoping that those fast
flows will rub off
[Laughter]
what did you say david gandy said a
sicario cinematic universe
yeah man [ __ ] uplift that goddamn
cartel
a look at the drug war from different
points of view interacting the
the dea frontline cops courts lawyers
etc
kind of cinematic law and order kind of
you know more beheadings and kind of a
breaking bad universe
wire neckties yeah they did i mean you
got breaking bad you got better call
saul which deals a lot with
similar subjects actually and then of
course el camino
so i feel like i honestly feel like the
breaking bad universe
already has the sicario thing uh already
like
done if you watch better call saul if
you're up to date on better call saul
you'll see that it's it's pretty similar
yeah but i will say that um
a sicario one could lend itself to a
little bit more of a
action action-based one which would be
cool because i think the action in
sicario is
pretty sweet because you don't really go
like ooh action movie because it's such
an intense film and it's not about the
action
let's face it the action is pretty
[ __ ] cool in that movie yeah it's
also one of those movies where like the
they make the dramatic moments extra
intense
hello anthony and bart oh my god i gotta
shout out this comment in the chat
oh what is it i gotta shout it out
it says from a man named aaron paul
blart mall cop
meets dawn of the dead i would [ __ ]
love it if
you're doing a paul blart three and then
suddenly it just turns into dawn of the
dead these people invade the ball
he has to protect them from the zombies
that would be so funny you could
already see it you could already see it
i i'm
i want that and i think i would go i
would
if it was literally a paul blart movie i
would
still watch that opening night guys i
hope okay
that's what i'll break quarantine for
hellboy versus ghostwriter that's
another great one right there
i'm hellboy all right okay okay oh we're
not too bad not too bad not too bad
we're not too bad not too bad we gotta
go oh no we're pretty behind
all right we got some people we can
double up i just i just
went way to the bottom and we're pretty
behind oh my god
all right all right niraj is back we're
going to catch up
with efficiency and focus here and we're
going to go through this we got this all
right niraj says the hitman thank you by
the way my friend
hitman series and the transporter series
universe combined that
sounds like it would be a natural fit i
mean i mean yeah that's a great call i
mean i think the hitman would win
yeah yeah based on the characters yeah
yeah
i'm like uh one's a better franchise
movie uh but yeah
if a hitman would win but you do have
your your realm of like cheesy
assassins and you got like your actual
cool assassins like bon
born wick then you got your you know
transporters and hitman so i think that
actually would be a good goal man
um hitman and and transporter somebody
i'd love to see that
somebody else also shouted out a
roboblart instead of a robocop that'd be
[ __ ] great
sylvester freisen jr back attack
supernatural
meets stranger things and ghostbusters
thanks buddy
okay supernatural means stranger things
and ghostbusters
can you imagine sam and dean with proton
packs
i think i saw elite i think i saw an
image circulating that occurs in the
final season of them with proton packs
on
or in ghostbusters outfits no spoilers
yeah no don't don't okay i'm not gonna
read the regular chat for a little bit
because i said that
let's just scroll up right here yeah
let's just scroll up to make sure
nothing again and then we'll scroll back
down to that comment
so uh yeah i mean with supernatural um
a ghostbuster i i would love to there's
jokes about it
that sam and dean uh gen i remember
seeing one of the compilations sent to
us
of jensen echols acting saying like if
they were in the walking dead universe
of how
how it would go and they would just
[ __ ] they would they'd kill it in the
walking dead university and they just
[ __ ] they survive easily
yeah um but i would be fascinated to see
them cross over into the walking dead i
think there's a version where it could
work
oh well yeah actually yeah you could do
it through supernatural not the walking
dead no the walk if you did through the
walking dead be like what the [ __ ]
what's going on here we are now we got
like weird in-dimensional traveling [ __ ]
but you do have supernatural you can
make it happen yeah yeah because then
you wouldn't have to also worry about
like
where were all the other creatures in
the walking dead they should just walk
in
on the moment when uh negan is beating
the heads
of abraham
dad what are you doing here
this is just new life out on the road oh
my god
change oh my god we gotta get back to
our room and
hey negan is is mourning a lost wife
it works all you would do is need to
change the bat's name
that's all you gotta do brittany lang
brittany lang hey brittany lane glad to
have you back here
we ought to hang brittany lang brittany
lang
how to kick cause britney lang likes to
bang and she does it when her man
is in a position to be hanged that's
right they're freaky as [ __ ]
pretty lame thank you autoerotic
asphyxiation hey guys how's it going
it's going well thank you for
brightening our day
hope you're doing well question do you
guys have tick-tock
we do not have it we do not i don't
think i'm gonna
i don't think i'm gonna do it there's so
many networks i don't think i'm gonna by
the time we have a tick-tock
legit following there will be a new
social network started up
i'm sticking to the ones that i think
will last yeah instagram and twitter
i'm just gonna stay there for now it's
gonna hold tight maybe
once i started up i did sort of vine
started getting a bit of a vine
following the vine shut down
uh and tick tock government's gonna shut
them down you know why
cause the chinese can see your [ __ ] or
something
is that why i don't know i heard one
person say that
but i'm gonna roll with that story yeah
why not sylvester freisen jr is back
thank you for all of your generosity
today uh my hero academia one
punch man dragon ball crossover that
would be
a formidable cross but but would saitama
not win
i think side demo will be oh yeah that's
kind of a
good call that's a tough question but
that would be the fun part of it is
watching them try to figure i feel like
if you teamed up they're all trying to
beat one punch man
yeah that would have to there's so many
heroes you have to have them verse
themselves
and my hero i could i i'd be content
with just my hero in a dragon ball
crossover yeah
that'd be pretty sweet if you just had
those two and then saitama comes in at
the end to sort it all out yeah
yeah yeah he just shows up as like a
surprise
to the audience don't even advertise it
but tell you the anime genres have to
cross over like just let the shows do it
do these specials anime
yeah anime people are like anime people
watch our live streams for sure
definitely they love our live streams
i'm not bragging when i'm talking about
sir dragon
but you know what i i think that you can
solve a mystery with our man dragon as
if he's going around with robert landon
he's the dragon soldier wiring me up
like folgers and he's going little
bolder
colorado aficionado
here to lay down some knowledge hmm
thank you by the way dragon oh [ __ ] we
got it we got a [ __ ]
epic comment here yes how about a horror
holiday universe where you have the
individual movies introducing a hero
that has to fight a holiday figure gone
bad before the big feature when they all
collide
okay so a horror holiday universe
wait a minute like all the holidays
i guess so yeah but then you turn you
culminate them into a horror movie
yeah so you have like the christmas
holiday
and you have hanukkah and
you have i guess you could labor day you
can do any haul it well
here's the thing is i feel like you
could definitely do any holiday with a
human figure attached to it so you got
your
santa or you know your krampus something
that has a sentience to it
and then you could take things like i
don't know how a labor day would work
i guess it would be like a reanimated
post office worker or some [ __ ]
but you know if it's like arbor day evil
treat
you just like bring bring monsters out
of the stuff that's not based on actual
humans and then uh
yeah you could have sort of a mascot for
every major day
that'd be fun plus as these sequels get
more and more desperate we can start
branching out into the
daily holidays like uh like july 14th
was national uh
national nude day okay so that
you know and there's like nationals talk
like a pirate day that's a real thing
so uh there's endless possibilities no
sweet yeah so
dragon soldier get that battalion
together and and start marching
i'm surprised no one in this chat would
know what i've noticed not a single
person in this chat
not one not once
star trek and star wars you think one
person wouldn't work there's no way
have you seen the jj abrams star trek
films it just wouldn't
work especially with the jj abrams star
wars this wouldn't work
it doesn't wouldn't make any sense
yeah i'm surprised actually i think
those would work just all right we've
gotten a couple of dc
and marvel yeah we've even gotten marvel
and star wars
but why wouldn't starfleet i haven't
seen one person say
star wars and star trek this entire time
we've been live
starfleet would make sense in the star
wars world
of course it would yeah it's space drive
why not
why not what are they they could easily
bump it we both went into hyper drive
and what the [ __ ] we bumped into each
imagine just imagine you could use
star trek as a means of diversifying the
star wars universe in its own lane
and then you know by canonizing all that
[ __ ] then you can avoid conflicts
a joke or an american psycho crossover i
wonder who would win
yeah this is just it's joaquin phoenix
being like his
his shade of white face paint is so much
more pale than mine
thanks for anne b for being here from
tijuana mexico oh good golly who do we
got here
wes poppies west poppies or or west
papes
mouth the gape when i talk to wes paige
and he feeds me some grapes and i
go boom boom like a [ __ ] ape
catch it all on tape yeah you can't feel
less when you're hanging around wes
who's definitely the best what's he got
to say
thank you is what i gotta say universal
monster movie verse that leads into
a monster squad remake dude the monster
squad is the thing that everyone's
really on about especially in iso 11
well that's the thing is the monster
squad who literally provides you with a
team-up movie in search of a
right well i think universal monsters is
i think they're
subtly i think they're kind of like
redoing the dark universe
they're just not saying it they're
low-key they're waiting
for like all right now we can see it
yeah
dark universe is being remade into the
leewanella verse
because lee wannell is supposedly the
front runner for
the the wolfman movies so with ryan
gosling
which which i'm cool for i was almost
about to be like here's what i got you
know lee one l directing this
you know uh but actually yeah i [ __ ]
love that
yeah it would work heck yeah bradley
banks west i think that was your first
time you ever super chatted us thank you
miss
very much appreciate you um and also we
got bradley bledsoe in here who's a
recent
uh addition to our patreon fam welcome
bradley
side note whenever i hear the name wes i
think of the uh nicole from
uh the [ __ ] baking show um
my god i really should eat more before
we ever do live streams
what is the bacon show i watch oh buyer
yeah yeah
um anyway so
bradley thanks bradley bradley bledsoe
with my new flow and i bled so much that
i
can't know when i like to go around here
do the disco with the go go where
bradley bledsoe
catch it on a gopro see him on the
schmos no
so thank you bradley hey guys
coming from patreon again thanks for the
shout out last time it made my day i'm
glad to hear that
uh i would personally love to see a
half-life portal cinematic universe
based on valve's games party on dudes
you didn't do it party on dudes
you didn't do it party on dude that's
how abe lincoln says it at the end of
the movie
well argued thank you
i know that enunciation coming from
patreon yeah i'm not familiar with the
half-life portal cinematic
as well as i oughta be half-life
the thing is there are only two
half-life games
and it's such a meme that the third one
will never be finished or made
so i'm wondering how much space you
would have to operate but
like portal won so many game of the year
awards i don't know how you would
adapt portal into a narrative it's
making me think about how you ha
they don't really do many game
crossovers anymore no
they used to be a thing you usually you
get them like pretty consistent with
fighting games now
especially in like the dlc areas but
beyond that
you they do that with fighting games a
lot you know like marvel dc
mortal kombat capcom all that all that
[ __ ] um
which are like their own franchises and
those those are crossovers already
but it would be cool to see them like
develop especially ones with their own
umbrella
naughty dog ubisoft whatever where
they can figure out a way to cross them
over i think that'd be really fun
especially when like the gameplays are
kind of similar to one another yeah you
can figure it out
and i think more i think people will be
on board with that i mean video the
thing i i assume
holds this up is the video game
development for quality games is
expensive but
i i feel like video game is is
perhaps like one of the best places to
do crossovers
like that because it puts it's what most
people want is not
even only just to see that happen but
also to get to engage with it and play
it you know so i
i'm surprised yeah there hasn't been as
much as that um i'm
i'm surprised also that for as much of a
legacy as half-life has it's never been
attempted as a
i don't think it's been attempted as
live-action thing but uh who's to say
never lose your nerd never drink booze
with a bird
don't go cruising a turd don't trust a
moo in a cow herd godzilla thank you by
the way godzilla monster universe
and pacific rim crossover destroy all
monsters
and robots starring
charlie charlie hunter john boyer girl
uh yeah that would be that would work
just fine that would work great i would
want i
i would probably root for godzilla still
wait a minute though the pacific rim
universe i i
you would have okay so our is the idea
actually
it would work because the problem with
these godzilla and king cog movies is
you they make like
human characters which are nowhere near
as intriguing as just wanting to see the
monsters do their thing
where the great thing about pacific rim
is that going
into the jaegers gives you a uh
you naturally you have to give a [ __ ]
about the characters you have to focus
on the characters
because it wouldn't work without the
characters the yeagers require the
humans the egg
and the jaeger yeah creates a nice
bridge i think where you can go oh yeah
my characters who i hopefully care about
are in there but also now we have a cool
stuffer for the fight
so if you have the kaiju alongside the
godzilla
kaiju and then you need the jaeger
people to fight them it would work
are you okay john i am dying really i'm
so unwell
i'm falling into this desk what is
happening right now i'm just getting a
bottle opener because i'm thirsty
okay don't worry don't worry it's all
live it's part of real life
but yeah i think that would actually uh
that's not where you want to do that
but uh yeah that that's actually not a
bad idea thanks never loser nerd
thank you i appreciate the communication
on you getting up and doing that john
i thought he was leaving the live stream
i'm sorry i thought that i could just
make it
oh yes that is a huge part of it don't
want to be aware of other people's
bodilies
anissa's back anisa as expected
a movie university of you and john plus
eric and i in a zombie apocalypse
that's it that's all i got sorry no
that's great anissa thanks for the super
chat
yeah i think we would make a good zombie
team i've wanted to make a real reject
short film
of um of greg is missing
oh no and then john goes on a hunt to
try to find greg
so so then every guest that's ever been
on the channel cameos
because he's going to all their homes
trying to find them and then at the end
he comes back here and i'm here
and i'm just like i was never missing
john
i've staged this whole kidnap i just
wanted to see if you really care about
me
i'm touched and then you kill me
how could you do this to me because
that's how guys solve their problems
violence
yeah man i'll punch but i appreciate
that nissan of course i would love to be
in a cinematic universe with you guys
and
eric horseman following it up of course
eric horseman more like eric of course
men
that's good i like that uh lol
anisa there's still alcohol available in
a zombie apocalypse right
of course man that's the currency of a
zombie apocalypse at this point
and you're gonna be the character who
gets drunk
to get effective so like when eric gets
[ __ ] up
you know he's gonna level like a crowd
of zombies and then like some kind of
bio creature who's the boss
you know ooh the boys and the walking
dead i gotta shout out that comment that
i see in the live stream right now
that's a great one
that would be a great crossover ooh we
got a new name we got a new face with a
mustache it's
brian konlow on the down low
with his mustache bro on his
face looking up down all over the place
he's got a suggestion of the cinematic
universe while i'm talking in verse to
brian konlow
oh we talking to brian when he be buying
all this [ __ ] that you be lying about
ooh jim carrey v russell brand oh he
just watched this dawn of justin he just
wants to see jim and carrie and russell
brandt fight each other
yeah man this is right by celebrity
death match yes
and and and and jim carrey and russell
brown would be both great because they
are both funny men
who have spiritually reformed yeah
heavily in the past years
but there's a difference there is
russell brennan has not lost his funny
no that is true in fact i think he's
funnier now
yes and also i mean he's getting chiller
and wittier now
yeah yeah whereas jim carrey's like
comedy was a form of repression and i
hate to tell you guys that but that's
all it was for me
oh buddy i guess that's how you'd be
that funny
yes anisa's back have y'all
ever heard of h-e-b in texas
no i have it in issa oh is that the
house of blues
i'm not sure h-e-b-tex texas
all right he's taking heb has been
preparing for covid
oh it's a meat place it's a food place
wait a minute i don't know just tell us
in the chat anissa
just tell us this looks like a grocery
or something like that
what is an heb should i be shopping
there is that where i should be spending
my money
uh i don't know i'm working on uh being
more informed as a consumer
and uh being more deliberate with who i
buy from so i'm just looking at the chat
right now
to see if anybody spoiled that yeah
right erica tuesday erica anywho
we have not heard of the agent we
haven't heard of the head i'm sorry
i haven't heard of the habit enlighten
us ringy
542
ringy ring these rhymes are going to be
a little dingy
yes they are a little bit
pinky hearing rattling sounds
we need snacks when we do these live
streams we do we need like a bowl of
don't you notice when john campbell does
his live streams he's always like
munching on hot dogs and chili burgers
that's right he's always in mid bite
when he's talking
ultimate mouth fuller that's the mouth
that's just so
funny every time you're watching it's
like rant about robert pattinson
he's got like a mouth full of like
onions and jelly and it's just spraying
into the camera
[ __ ] work out robert
see the microphone covers and the pop
filters just
covered in dried saliva uh
tmnt and resident evil thank you ringy
542 tmnt and resident evil
oh interesting the ooze that made the
turtles could be created by umbrella
corps
that's fascinating that's plausible
because half of i mean resident evil
isn't just zombies it's it's bio-organic
monstrosities as well wow this is so
[ __ ] um this ooze is a goddamn
free-for-all isn't it
you know do anything it creates turtles
it's the spring it's a
rat to life [ __ ] make zombies it's
the l sparks
it's a mcguffin that does everything it
does everything we need it to do for the
plot
anything and everything it's a
mysterious goose whatever
but no i think uh tmnt fighting zombies
would not be bad
that would be pretty cool for that's the
funny thing about the zombie genre you
can cross over the zombie genre with
almost
any any property marvel vs zombies who
the [ __ ] want to see that batman
versus zombies
who wouldn't want to see that uh quick
shouts out
to my man scotty fields this guy i
haven't spoken to in a long time but i
know man he did
a marvel zombies short that's on youtube
way a while back but it's actually
pretty fun and the production values are
also uh kind of gooey and nice so you
know who's gonna appreciate
that shout out who scottie scotty
and no one else scotty feels that's the
thing when you name drop someone they're
like oh god quick shout out
they appreciate that well i mean i can't
remember if his channel was called the
scotty
okay shields okay i'm just saying but
anyway find his markers we're not making
as big of a difference as you think you
are i am making
the difference living freak
living freak oh we shouted about earlier
how about
a spaghett thank you again how about a
spaghetti western crossover thank you
i feel like that would definitely lend
itself i mean but what do you mean you'd
have to start
okay but you start all the way from the
beginning right uh and the first
spaghetti he's not no he's not just
talking about it
gotta go back we're going back to the
origins of spaghetti
because that's when the italian nation
was was was established
we're in loop-de-land right now our
dinghy
uh uh okay no yeah i mean you
wait a minute though planet of the day
what would a spaghetti western crossover
be
exactly which would be a spaghetti
western but with a lot of recognizable
characters like you would do
individual spaghetti western movies and
eventually have them cross over with
each other
is that the is that the conceit here i
guess so i guess you would have to have
some kind of connective tissue and and
then yeah have
an array of ensembles or or rambo versus
rocky
that is an appropriate matchup
those two need to fight i'm just saying
that that would be just as entertaining
as a spaghetti western crossover
agreed i wouldn't mind it
you could call red dead redemption
franchise yeah
i mean the thing is there i feel like
with a lot of westerns
there's not a lot separating them from
occupying the same world unless they're
the exact same
story being told because you know you're
just in the frontier
you just have them versus zombies i mean
everything works with
i was thinking i saw somebody talking
about a planet of the apes and i was
like
crash playing of the apes the dead
franchise
back anissa the ellen
cinematic universe she's she's said it
twice she's super chatted twice and said
the ellen cinematic universe
a double and eric horseman thank you
well done and russo gaming
oh
and they're saving us four questions
worth of time now anissa
you said uh you contributed twice
in honor of the bernie sanders campaign
no refunds yes
yes what in honor of our of our beloved
lost fallen candidate our fallen
candidate
leaving us with no no just message me
i'll figure it out
but thank you anisa and eric and uh
this allen cinematic universe there's
gonna be
there's gonna be a biopic of ellen
degeneres one day
and it's gonna be the most over-the-top
dramatic [ __ ] we've ever
it's gonna be so dark but you can see it
you can see it
like this this comedian who was a closet
homosexual right
she comes out loses her show she's put
in this terrible spotlight but she's
like uh this activist this uh
person who's champion and uh being gay
in hollywood and being open and
outspoken
then she gets her show beloved but then
she becomes this egotistical
hollywood celebrity and like goes from
someone who was important and meaningful
to this this is the woman who everyone
despises
and then miss mojo makes a [ __ ] ton of
videos about oh
no right you could already see the movie
and then it
ends i don't know how
would the interview that she did with
whoever played anastasia steel
and 50 shades of grey oh don johnson's
daughter
yeah dakota johnson yeah yeah yeah that
one
oh so all you gotta do is hate on hate
on her you're good sorry i've been doing
a little game yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing body rot
just pitched a jack slater from the last
action hero versus howard
we're focused on these chats right now i
am
the next one comes with swam off
chris wham-off man or is it womof
i'm off you're off walmart
looking tougher hanging out with
christopher getting buffer
getting around here and i look at him
getting buffer and i started to do a
jack off with my chris wham-off and a
blam off with the stam off and then man
ma'am
this a league of extraordinary
samuel l jackson character delirious
territory
a league of extraordinary samuel l
jackson's character
work watching what does that mean i
appreciate the super chat so
i don't know what you're talking about
is this a league of extraordinary
gentlemen but where every role is played
by sam jackson or is this a league of
extraordinary gentlemen in which
every character is a different uh
every character is a league of
extraordinary samuel jackson
uh so you're just watching a whole bunch
of different sam jackson's so it's like
we got jewels we got the guy from uh
deep blue sea
that would be a guy from an intense
yellow jurassic no i'm not yelling
that's how i talk
ain't you seen my movies kiss my ass
[ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] you know what
this you know this franchise to be
called
shaft they deserve to die and they
deserve to burn in hell
actually that third shaft movie the one
directed by tim story
that's the thing i don't know why i said
it's the third shaft movie that
it's not it's not the third shaft movie
but that shaft movie is
really [ __ ] funny is just to feature
the title shaft
it's a super funny movie i was
pleasantly surprised by how funny that
movie was
i want to see it now anisa's back and
she says i love y'all
cracker on you i just have all of my
being
okay uh i do i got it yes
uh i don't have a crack you don't have a
cracker
i do have uh like a like a kind bar you
want a kind bar nah
[ __ ] that it's like granola and [ __ ]
okay is it dairy
no i don't believe so now we're good
i mean i have like a a scone if you want
a piece
nah i'm good all right anisa says i love
y'all
with an emoji heart nissa i love you too
it's hard to do this with a mic
anissa oliver getting john's dick so
much thicker
when he thinks of you yeah i love you
too
i wanna i want uh to know how many
impressions you all can do
all right okay i can do any impression
as long as i'm doing adam sandler doing
the impression
that's how simple it is i'm bernie
sanders
hey i'm robert de niro you're talking to
me you're talking to me
this is beautiful i feel like he's
really happy as long as i'm doing
adam sandler impersonating someone i
could do whatever impression you want me
to do
hell's yeah man i have no idea how many
impressions we can do
i can only do the one impression of
nicholas cage yeah
well that answers that you know what i
mean neil that's what i need to do
neil eric horstmann's back but
i mean john is really good at impress he
doesn't get enough credit for how good
jaundice and impressions john do us
speed random impressions will you
okay look i think we're both really
hungry and sweaty
mr white [ __ ] i don't want to cook
today
yo okay nicholas cage nicholas cage
uh i'm a treasure protector all right
all right
uh [ __ ] uh daniel craig from knives
out
or i mean that's not very fair because
i'm just doing an accent
that he is also doing but i don't feel
like i sound that much like him
tell me why though you see you got to
see you have to express yourself you
don't
hurt anyone you see the room 200 time
maybe johnny is vampire
arnold schwarzenegger you know i was
fantastic
i was the governor of california and uh
i wanted to put a new mask into
a [ __ ] barack obama uh
the american people desire
to see uh rambo cross over with the
terminator
[Laughter]
part of philadelphia that was really
funny skynet
will not receive any tax cuts
it's not as good the second time but but
yeah there you go there's a couple lines
were still
there's a handful for you eric horseman
this is just a super chat test just to
make sure they're working
it's it's totally working eric thank you
thank you for making sure the bell works
anissa again test test one two three
testing what are you guys doing stop
everyone's just testing with money you
don't have to do that buddy
thank you for making sure the bell works
uh oh we'll name that movie where are we
we just got reset oh no
gorilla geek 27
gorilla geek a thriller freak
killer make you say eat oh man
i'm filipino from manila hanging out on
my friend gorilla
gear was it geek i'm sorry man i'm so
blowing up like dante's peak i don't
know what happened around the two hour
mark i was just like
cutting dicks off i am so hungry
i might need to step out to grab some
chips wooden that's all i need is some
chips and i'll be fine
chipping um a cinematic universe within
a cinematic universe
it's called marvel mcu
is already there literally every
character is their own they already have
their own cinematic universe already
man cinematic universe and cinematic
universe with comic books it's like
mlm marketing isn't it yes it is
multi-level marketing
multiverse marketing if you convince
this hero to make a franchise and then
they invite three of their hero friends
to make a franchise then all those
franchises cross over
that's not bad no in fact you could you
know what i want is a cinematic universe
about people making a cinematic universe
and then you know
that's the way of any good independent
comedy writer starting right over there
film about people making a film mark
leach thank you buddy the nice guys
kiss kiss bang bang shaba you know the
nice guys was originally supposed to be
like a sequel to kiss kiss bang bang
something like that there was something
that's cool some talk about that
that would work and so i actually kissed
kiss bang bang and the nice guys
crossing over
that would be [ __ ] rad awesome that
would get gay perry in there get
you got uh downey jr yeah yeah
those are the characters john yeah
that would be it um yeah that would be a
blast the nice guys and kiss kiss bang
bang
kiss the nice guys and then and then
don't stop there
get the predator kiss the nice guys bang
the predator and trevor slattery get
them all in there boom
eric eric horstmann answer me this
lucifer versus crowley who would win
it's [ __ ] lucifer he's gonna win
in supernatural or just the characters
or the character lucifer from lucifer
versus crowley from supernatural i mean
lucifer will always win he's the ruler
of hell
yeah he's think about it like this if
crowley is forced off this earth
where is he gonna go to hell
by lucifer crowley was it was a g but
crowley
if i'm understanding the context right
also like peaced out to avoid lucifer
it's very hard yeah it's hard to beat
the devil
even if you're in a bmw film anissa
oliva is back
what do you think is going to happen in
the season five finale of supernatural i
would like
to hear y'all's theories well thanks for
the question nisa
what i think is gonna happen is that
they're gonna set up for season six
at the end of season five of
supernatural oh my
um spoilers whoa i think they'll send
lucifer back to hell
i'm afraid look at the chat right now i
think they'll send lucifer back to hell
but all the way up they'll be setting
themselves up in a position where all
the other gods are gonna be
really like uh they're gonna be set up
as opposing threats
because now the the the the table's open
and exactly can you
swoop in exactly now let's not look at
the chat so that way no one beats a dick
in the chat
season finale both sam and dean say
yes and then the rest of the show
continues with lucifer and michael yes
um are you looking for spoilers right
now in the main chat is that what you're
doing
no tempting fate
greg get a juice box that's what
everyone's saying
oh yeah get a juice box buddy
i'm pretty sure people have actually
been tuning in because my cat from hell
was on
it did wonders we have 134 concurrent
viewers and 141 likes it's pretty decent
it's pretty good we haven't even pushed
the likes yeah
except in the description box
yeah i'm going to get a i'm going to i'm
going to get something to eat i'm going
to get like some chips
john get a snack with two john hold it
down i need to get some chips
you got it i'm gonna go through this
chat right here we're gonna hang out
together
all right guys guys guys guys
thank you again for being here sound off
if you are here for the uh
my cat from hell if you came in here
because of my cat from hell i think that
would be very amusing
and i would like to know sojin choi choi
sojin choi i like that you wrote cdsv
levram i don't know why
i would like a trend of uh comments
being written
in the backwards uh back to the future
meets bill and ted allison harding
actually
sounds like it could it could work
decently i mean part
of me isn't actually for some weird
reason against revisiting the back to
the future
universe if we could get uh michael j
fox in there somehow in a way that isn't
you know distasteful or something like
that but um
tm what movement is catching on that
you're talking about right now the greg
get a juice box
movement gremlins versus chucky that
would actually be a pretty good one
because both of those are like
kid-centric
i would love a baked lay get laid
and don't fret about fried chips it's
weird i feel so much better now
that's all all you need is a little bit
of that
you know glycemic boost sorry i was i i
didn't
normally i tried to have like a couple
of snacks before we go live and then i
was like oh [ __ ] i did not i
barely ate today it just hit me it's
okay though because the chat is calling
you a snack
and they're not spoiling anything so
people just think you're hot
all right all right good omens are we
talking about the show good omens i saw
an episode and i
i liked the pilot uh i would like to
finish
tonight mark leach guten knocked
all right john let's bring back those
super chats let's go to the people soups
and nieces what time are we at we are at
6 27 p.m
we are we are within 40 minutes all
right guys time to get super sharp here
anissa says john yell southern accent
gets me every time
now say something really sweet and
romantic to anissa anisa
your spirit is that of the oleander
purest white
and your love and affection makes my
heart
swell to the point of bursting
i don't know you're a mint julep in the
summertime i don't know why you're
actually cracking
you're a chestnut in the winter
those are some good some good 11 11
spoonfuls for you
if i if i die early before you
which is going to happen not likely but
if i
die
um you have to you have to
do the eulogy in in that voice gregory
albo
was a thoughtful man you have to do that
his spirit was as expansive as the mall
of america
wait what is this thing about you
attacking me
oh i think people are trying to pit us
against each other by using the fact
that you were out of the room as a means
of slandering me
that you said something to me seriously
what would you say about me
i just professed my undying love i sure
which is a compliment which is a good
thing which means you're tasty which
means people think you're hot
did you tell them about the time you i
did
because you're a snack lick my butt hole
that was a chocolatey treat right there
john humphries canceled it
for agreeing for yes ending greg's
[ __ ] up okay wait a minute wait a
minute if we live in the day and age we
do no one's getting canceled over
[ __ ] all right [ __ ] just got
accepted in the mainstream
okay people get shamed for not [ __ ]
go watch me on my cat from hell go watch
greg get rimmed on my cat
hell eric horstmann's back battlestar
galactica and westworld
dolores and maeve versus number six and
boomer
i mean i pick maeve all day i love maeve
i i
i feel like there's a wait a minute but
didn't game of thrones already cross
over with westworld because the dragon
was in an episode of westworld
oh my god i went to some room where
there was a where the dragon was there
i wouldn't be surprised so wait are we
seeing the all of game of thrones
is literally just yuppie tourists living
out
a role play yeah and that's why it ended
so disappointingly because all these
yuppie tourists didn't really think it
through
it makes sense it tracks the storyline
writers of the park did not do a good
job on that
you know it's you know it's a great live
stream chewing on chips into the
microphone
that's a great live stream
also make for a better podcast if we did
it that way yeah
this is now an asmr mukbang let us eat
into your ears
oh we got a couple we got a few here
from sylvester thank you sylvester
sylvester fry's on junior says astro boy
versus elita battle angel now that would
be
fun that would be fun i would think neo
versus a little
elita battle angel would also be a great
one too
thank you yeah and then he also says
blade
meets supernatural and sabrina the
teenage witch
blade versing the winchester boys that
would actually be a
really sweet crossover that would be
cool plus i'm not
like you could open it up for maybe at
the end they might team up or they could
just remain enemies like yeah
sterling k brown style yeah i mean let's
face it that would be actually
the best i think that's the one that
i've heard so far other than the
detective someone in the chat who pushed
mentioned detective
um going on uh investigative like film
sets that are
like haunted like exorcist i
totally said that terribly but but that
one and the blame and supernatural one
have to be my favorite ones
good picks is also saying uh kingsman
versus kill bill
huh wait a minute who's okay so it's
like the uh
the viper the deadly viper assassination
squad versing the kingsman
or is it or is it um thurman's the bride
versus kingsman
i mean each could work i feel like um
the bride versus the kingsman is the
more personal story but
i mean you could argue that the same way
the statesmen
have a theme and are a similar
organization you could just expand
the the uh uh what are they called you
know the snakes you can spam that
assassin ring and just make it its own
uh you know organization the swordsman
and that's what it'll be called can you
switch over a bit
thanks man no problem
[Laughter]
professionally going to get so
comfortable with this live stream format
that there will be no rules we're going
to be like just
completely like there's not even a
camera on us at a certain point yeah
you know just keeping it real natural
here on the live stream studio
i'm just gonna live stream with the
camera on and we're gonna be editing for
two hours
and not show them at all what we're
doing all right we got another one from
from our boy here from sylvester thank
you for all the super chats that are
sylvester it's really sweet
thank you appreciate it samurai jack
meets tmnt
and batman is samurai jack your
protagonist i would have to say samurai
jack
and tmnnt would be the one that excites
me the most about that one
yeah you know batman and not i know
there's like ninja batman but if you put
batman in some animes that'd be [ __ ]
awesome
like yeah you do like a legit batman
anime that's just like
contemporary or timeless yeah or like a
batman anime show like it's it's
anime style batman the anime
series that would be cool right i think
that would be awesome you get like
actual
artists from japan who develop animes to
do an anime batman show
because yes there's the ninja batman i'm
fully aware of that movie
i'm saying you do an actual series i
think that would be really great
anime meets batman show yeah
oh goodness things are happening ramiro
sanchez
is back thanks ramiro oh no tomorrow i
work at 6am and can't stay on any
further good night
well thank you for saying good night
with a nice tip thank you buddy that's
really sweet of you
and i hope you're having a good rest i
hope you're waiting
for your chat to be read to this point
sylvester is back once more after romero
fantastic four meets doom patrol and the
boys
ooh so it's at least for the boys it's
just another version of the seven except
less i mean fantastic four meets doom
i think doom patrol and the boys
crossing over would be
a match made in heaven i like one part
of me wanted to say umbrella academy and
and uh doom patrol but
i don't know there's something that's a
little too similar about the way the
shows are kind of done
dude patrol's a little bit more out
there actually but doom patrol and the
boys
i think would be a perfect match made in
heaven if you've seen it if you've seen
both those shows i i think you would
strongly agree with me
um a fantastic four i don't know they're
kind of too kid-friendly if you ask me
yeah fantastic four's is uh very pg-13
area like everything about fantastic
four reads pg-13 to me
i don't read as much edgy yeah whereas
like the boys and dude patrol very hard
r so i you would have to keep it uh
i don't know doom patrol umbrella
academy and the boys i'd be more on
board for
but hey it's your super chat so [ __ ]
yeah let's do it man
all right fl okay
blade versus underworld is a great
picture that is
so natural why has no one said that
sheepers
i don't i don't think i've even heard of
that before yeah would it blade versus
underworld who's this person
i fell a
fl okay that's more than okay right now
i gotta say
that you're making me pray that blade
versus
underworld happens one day boom boom
boom nailed it that's what i call
rhyming [ __ ]
[ __ ] hoes sylvester fryson jr is back
rambo
versus the terminator i think oh well
yeah rambo versus the terminator
[ __ ] i don't know if i'd actually i
can't oppose that
then you could get your actual proper
arnold versus
uh stallone movie yeah we haven't gotten
a pro like
maybe the other expendables and escape
plan but that would be the
perfect one rambo is a human computer
when it comes to murdering people and
the
terminator is a computer oh my god that
would be perfect
that would be yeah like of all the
humans out there like well equipped to
to
stand a chance is there a comic of that
oh
write it make that your passion project
is there a comic of it there should be
if there's not i feel like
that's the thing i would be curious
about is like how many uh like
how many of these things have we touched
upon that have some kind of
close counterpart as an actual comic
book crossover because like you know
that
there's uh like superman is versed
predator like there's all sorts of stuff
in the in the comics like that
so um that's dude
thank you sylvester anissa anisa's back
i'm going to take an asmr video on
behalf of reject nation
and we will all want it place we need it
we all what
i'm going to ask for an asmr video on
behalf of the reject nation we all want
it
please an emoji that this computer does
not recognize
we need it don't worry we'll get it
there nissa oh we appreciate the comment
super chap one day we will do an asmr
video
or maybe do it right we're reading off
anisa's super chats thank you so much
anisa
eric horstmann john is peeing in the
toilet cue that
peeing in the toilet sound have you
heard john p in the toilet
it's [ __ ] racehorse in there it's
weird it's not just one racehorse
it sounds like multiple racehorses it
actually is a harmony are there three
people peeing in that toilet right now
at different pitches
what the [ __ ] is going on in there this
is the most musical piss
john's penis is like the the this is
[Laughter]
one urethra was not a love crafty and
cinematic universe movie
wanting it's jon's janitor
urethra uh eric horseman
off topic just big love to the reject
fam double hearts love to you
thank you eric you make us feel so loved
you really don't need a super chat
anymore i appreciate it though but
um but thank you eric ooh so i don't
mean that so i don't mean that
keep supernatural thank you eric
sylvestre
sylvester and anissa you can don't break
your wall y'all
appreciate it killing it bad boys meets
the equalizer
oh i gotta give it to denzo i think
denzel will [ __ ] up both will smith
yeah they're they're too brash i really
think he's too calculated yeah well
denzel would [ __ ] up i i think bad boy
i think bad boys versus
denzel washington not even the equalizer
i think denzel would win
i just yeah i i it's hard to beat denzel
yeah especially with his like super
power level of autism in those movies
uh alto voltaire
alto volta devoted good get it john
voltai you got it john take the rhymes
away john
on oh damn it i gotta not use the ones
we used last time
uh alto voltaire
uh kicking ass like the dora melange
valuable and rare like a faberge egg
i got greg with me he's having a snack
with two c's just alto and me
to answer this question sam jackson
and gordon ramsay in a buddy cop movie
i love it i want it i want it
as gordon ramsay playing a character or
is gordon ramsay just gonna be himself
but on like a ride along
because i would want a gordon ramsay and
sam jackson movie
just so i could hear all the crazy
behind-the-scenes stories that happen
with those two arguing with each other
i want to hear the yelling match that
occurs after that and what
what crafty is like on that set
thanks alto that's a great call thank
you alto and i hope we're
in the ballpark of your name
again reject family is everything
love i am so grateful for you two and
this channel for helping create these
friendships and family
y'all are amazing yellow heart
once this channel is done i am never
talking to any of you again
yeah the day the lights go out the day
live cold turkey
goodbye eric
hoostman
what liver anissa
huh liver anyway
we love you i'm just joking we love you
we are down we
we everyone needs a snack you're right
you're absolutely right the whole chat
needs a snack
anissa oliver again again y'all's
their oppression sounded like yoda it is
so funny
also i'm so sorry from keeping you from
eating i feel bad
it's not just you it's not it's not it's
everyone's generosity this gives us
reading and also our own lack of
snacking it's also our own lack of
preparing that oh yeah we're doing a
live stream right we should have eaten
beforehand
yeah you know next time we make the
cocktails just bring in the chips
i'll supply the chips use your hand i
have my switch
uh what's up thank you anissa that's so
sweet of you oh the moment you know we
love the hell out of you
but here is where the question i've been
wanting to get to i saw this come up in
the regular
chat and i was like we have to make sure
we get to this question and you know
what else is great about this is that we
are
nearing the bottom of our uh super chats
and then we got some stream laps to wrap
up
and then we got a speed round of the
chats oh good so we don't have any
cropping at the bottom anymore are you
good
uh so nissa wants to no
what is [ __ ] asking for a friend well
john you brought up the [ __ ] so why
don't you tell the crowd what [ __ ] is
kids cover your ears
well greg it's funny you should ask
because technically you are the one who
broached the topic and i just named it i
brought up the
action you you brought up the defined
with the action you brought up the act
of licking someone's
uh anal sphincter their butthole
in layman's terms uh otherwise known as
a rim job
i really i really hope this is the part
where people who are watching my cat
from hell
yeah are going tuning in i want to check
out that guy's youtube channel
and then they come right here explain
what the rim
yeah maybe we can uh what's that movie
with the with the
uh julia roberts where uh she's
the stepmom or she or the nanny or
whatever where she like teaches the kids
what snow blowing is
and in school we watched that movie and
everyone was like oh what is snow
blowing and it created a monster
i feel like we're watching pizza no
no but
bat damon's first role is in that movie
oh
they do be [ __ ] at costco for cheap
thank you 50 50.
uh john hey eric also wants uh [ __ ]
explain tunisia
it's uh you know it's it's it's
analingus is what that is
just uh you know oral lovin on
the uh you know outward facing door
back door love orally speaking john
explain sex to me what is it oh john you
got all these super chats taken care of
sex is uh a
biological phenomenon determined
by genetics you can see john overly
highlighting everything
sex is are you uncomfortable explaining
this right now
no i'm trying to come up with like a
like a off the beaten path
joke to instead of just explaining what
sex
actually is uh sex
is complex when two people agree that
one of them
really needs something and the only
monetary
incentive one can provide is love
it's all transactional it's just
business
this isn't a joke it's not a bit i don't
know what's going on i
started as a joke for like i wanted to
do something how cold i make the ac in
here it's so hot it doesn't work
um you know sex is uh uh you know
the the what are you born as what are
you born you're a sex
one of them or a few of them i don't
know this is so could be anything
this is so good sex is the entirety of
the livestream will be based off of this
six is how guys think moving on
fella okay is back do you think we will
see
mahershala ali's blade meet jared leto's
morbius
i wow i didn't even think about that
i asked this question uh hold on a
second while i fixed the window it was
fel aka
akai okay uh do we think blay will meet
morbius
well after john's great explanations of
ribbing in sex i'm glad we could get on
this topic right now
my rooming explanation was much better
than my sexplanation
surprisingly i'm sure yeah i love how
you can explain what
rhyming is if you can't explain i can
explain sex but everyone knows what sex
is you know i wanted to come up with
something other yeah
i get you i want to be i get your job
and uh that's what you get
when you want to be clever you just get
this i don't i don't think we'll see
blade and morbius because
morbius seems so under the umbrella of
sony mm-hmm and unless
marvel they want to play with me marvel
does eventually you know
like buy sony completely out or at least
buy spider-man right out
then i think we're likely to see it but
i even think then it wouldn't be the
morbius
of jared leto's i think it would be a
different morbius but don't get me wrong
the idea of that happening
actually sounds very exciting yeah and
then we got
that's actually a really exciting thing
thanks for mentioning that that would be
like some cool fan stuff to see
i mean i mean and morbius and blade have
both been the first time i saw more of
using blade was in the spider-man 90s
animated show
so it's not out of this realm to think
it's possible no
i i feel like almost because also too
you have the murderer poster and the
tobey maguire speculation
the only reason i don't have more faith
in some kind of
you know uh shoestring of a chance is
just because
marvel is recasting and sony really
seems eager to work with them
so that's the only reason i would see
that not happening now let's read the
next super chat
you guys have been oh 50 50. that's
right uh
the ocarina of
[Laughter]
legend of zelda the ocarina of pain
we really get to know our viewers the
pornographers
that's what i do is the ocarina of pain
that sounds like a good old time
thanks 50 50. thank you 50 50. that
that's a 100 from me
you guys have been amazing says
sylvester fry's and junior thanks
sylvester
i've been subscribed to you for years
keep up the great
work and sylvester follows it up
minecraft versus fortnite now if i
played either one of those i'd probably
be excited but i'm sure the fans of
those would be very excited
that would make all the money because
minecraft and fortnite are like the most
popular games on earth right now and
sylvester i really do appreciate that uh
compliment you know like especially for
the people who have been
a thank you to everyone who's been here
since the beginning of this live stream
i know it's a long one
and also thank you to everyone who's
been subscribed for as long as you have
been or if you're brand new as well but
especially for the ones that have been
here for a few years it's pretty
baffling to me like damn it's right it's
been doing this a few years haven't we
so
thank you yeah i really do appreciate
sylvester and everyone else too thank
you it's humbling yeah that
i mean you know that you all would spend
time
over time you know returning here is is
yeah
really cool thank you uh in the last
super chat before we do the stream laps
yes and isa oliver's back you can't read
it guys because of the thing but
i tried uh rooming and golden showers
at the gas station you bet anybody wants
one
anissa i don't think you want a gold
john tell them what a golden shower is
oh well it's just really expensive you
know you get a bottle of goldschlager
and then you route it through your
plumbing and then it comes out in the
shop
but you know the bottle's not that big
and the gold flakes don't get
through the holes you redeemed yourself
from the sex explanation
i'm gonna leave now you really run you
really redeemed yourself
way to go thanks man so that's what that
is
oh we got one one one more eric
horstmann
[ __ ] glory holes and golden showers a
cinematic
universe that's just porn cinematic sex
first
dude thanks eric horseman i'm not going
to riff more on that but thank you
no we just need to bridge the gap you
know like porno can't be the only type
of film that has explicit sex in it so i
think
we should make those kinds of things
mainstream that former disney star
tried doing that what was her name which
one trying to do and what
uh what was she from she i don't
remember but i remember she was like a
uh
bella thorne she made a porno oh how she
directed it
oh she did she directed it she was
trying to make like something that had
more meaning
really yeah did it succeed i'm sure
you've seen it
i i honestly i don't know the the
prospect whenever anybody tries honestly
to make
a porno of some kind of an adult film an
erotic film that has some kind of
artistic merit or some kind of quality
to it i'm always like
you go yeah i hope you can do it i
really hope you can do it
uh mr vazoo
uh mr vajuz man i love erica a crossover
universe with back to the future
bill and ted's and ghostbusters i mean
back to the future in bill and ted's i
think would work
when they're time traveling you can get
lost in whatever [ __ ] portal
dimension thing that's happening
and then that's how you can cross them
over that works that actually works
hmm okay i'd be down i think bill and
weirdly even though back to the future
in bill and ted both deal with time
travel i feel like bill intending
ghostbusters would work better
yeah especially all the personalities
clashing with the whimsy
yeah cause like back to the future as
whimsy but it's a different kind and i
feel like they
put a lot more on like we can't screw up
the timeline whereas
ted you can do you can kidnap all of
history
exactly uh flef dorian's back and thank
you mr vaju again uh phleb doran it's
4 am here i'm clocking out it's 4am as
of an hour ago
no it wasn't from an hour ago my god
just about oh
yeah actually an hour and a few minutes
ago uh it's four am here clocking out
bye
love you both love you too flavio thank
you for any more
all the contributions you made today in
this room been amazing hopefully you
catch this
end piece part okay katie and
i'm not 100 sure what this means but she
says oh gee
greg og greg and oj
jaw i think she meant to put oj john at
the at the next to it
oh gee greg or maybe she's saying that
you remind her of oj
or maybe she's saying that your original
ryan wright persona needs to go and have
a fight with o.j simpson
way to yes and me i think what you said
is the right thing
and i would like to add more ideas on
top of it
would you say i'm like oj yeah i am okay
i'm totally
i love posting weird cryptic twitter
videos now that i'm out and free and
everyone
is a little odd i love
the way cuba gooding jr portrayed me on
tv
oh man thank you katie oh also keep your
eyes on the patreon tomorrow kdm
eric horseman back at it again aliens
and terminator
oh thank you eric ripley and sarah
connor
is there a fan fiction of this yet i
also like
i don't know i think there should be um
ripley and sarah connor teaming up is a
match made in heaven even today like
linda hamilton which he did with dark
fate and then
showing uh you know sigourney we were
looking at her now i'm like whoa they
could team up now and it'd still be
great
i agree and and also the the eric goes
on to say that they should team up
in all ways which i'm pretty sure means
we're getting a romance
sure it's again romance scissoring
romance same thing if you
look one up in the thesaurus you'll just
see i'm sorry damn it
being sex positive right now but thanks
eric that's a great call
wow that is that is a really good call
chill level tv i'm sorry if anyone
pitched this already
horror heroes universe well we kind of
did
at williams nancy thompson andy barclay
sydney prescott dale cooper t-800 ellen
ripley
major dutch sarah connor chris
washington tommy wiseau
connie's vampire lori hey actually
that'd be pretty fun
i don't know what kind of [ __ ] weird
hodgepodge of what super villain you
need them to go up against
trump the true trump bro
jeffrey fc we're all in
feature we america take this guy on and
they're all in the voting booth
and there's so much intensity as they
drop it in the ballot that'd be funny
the ballot box that's funny
oh man you know what uh this actually
kind of reminds me of i don't know if
the promo is on
online anymore but a friend of mine who
you know his name is matthew
um wrote and filmed a a sizzle reel
for a film that he was trying to sell
and i mean he's made other films since
then but he made this movie that was
basically about
the survivors of every situation that
went on to spawn
the freddy movies the jason movies etc
they're all brought
together in this experimental treatment
where they're put into like a virtual
reality where they have to go back into
their memories and confront them
to you know surpass the trauma and then
only to find that you know something's
gone wrong the doctor gets killed
they're all on their own and they're
stuck in the psych
and uh and this kind of reminded me of
that and if you can find the psych
teaser
which is p5ych because there are five
main characters
go find it it's a cool concept kind of
like this one
and i'm in it ryan chandler
oh boy thank god it's done
yeah your comment the thing you were
saying yeah oh thank god yeah
look out matthew's really going to
appreciate that and all the people here
are going to go check it out now
when i was in matthew's acting class i
often shared
he would have us go around and you know
uh
throw out like a good thing that
happened during the week or something
like that and i would often bring up
things
that that were successes in in this room
so matt does care
ryan chandler hey guys how about the
real rejects
wait wait ryan chandler the ultimate
handler
ryan chandler the ultimate handler um
he's a
[ __ ] uh friends with adam sandler god
damn yeah
yeah man handler i mean i said already
said handler oh you did chelsea handler
all right star spangled rhymes are dying
when i'm trying to come up with
something for ryan
ryan chandelier hey guys how about that
real rejects
meet the time bandits what famous
historical figures would you guys
rob with the time bandits i'd rob
i love that rob
steal all of her cakes
out good call yeah i would rob
uh thanks to the the contribution dude i
would rob
al capone rob jesus
steal no stealing like why don't you
have anything
no you know what you should do uh i'm
gonna take a syringe and steal some of
his blood and then try to duplicate him
no i got a better one
and then you'd make jesus in the 21st
century
i like it and john was denying me
already okay go john
they steal his body before he can
resurrect out of the tomb
[Laughter]
they break in steal his body they take
it
that is good thanks
i felt bad but in the moment i was like
this might be an okay one up
uh you know that plus you could get the
time bearing i think us
and the time band is like messing with
hitler i think would be fun just to like
really bust his chops up really ruin his
day
yeah um i wouldn't want to steal
anything from him but
uh who else is in history
just want to rob that al capone vault
let's do that i'd rob john wilkes booth
from his gun
that's a good one that's a good idea
yeah then i gave him a sniper now you
can do this more efficiently
and confuse the world with the special
advanced weapon you've been given
oh that's yeah because then you wouldn't
have to be right behind yeah
at first i was like why would you need
that from right behind somebody but then
i was like oh no you could do it far
away
take out more wow that would be
i'm trying to i want to make this joke
as dark as [ __ ] possible all right
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
alter history there
you're gonna massacre that you're gonna
ruin history a little bit
i'm not eating i'm eating i'm eating i'm
eating baked lays right now
there are two more supers chat oh there
you know what i love about ryan beatty
you like ryan beatty is our ultimate
moderator and beatty is the ultimate
model [ __ ] love him he kills the game
on our on our discord
server and uh two more super chats
we got a nissa once again i
am sorry for my inappropriateness i
usually don't oh sorry john i totally
cut you off
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
that's inappropriate
i'm sorry for my inappropriateness i
usually don't talk like this
sorry but this has been so fun
this is fun really you know what's fun
john wilkes booth with a sniper rifle
never no i would not be a cool dad you
would be a very cool dad
i wouldn't i would intentionally hit the
kid
unlike all the tattoo unintentionally
it was an accident i didn't mean to go
into the next
room and grab my belt oh boy
why are her jokes going get a stick make
a switch
and then um last one of the day
has anyone brought up constantine and
hellboy universe combined
ooh cool actually i feel like that could
be one of those things that starts out
with their enemies but then they team up
well yeah obviously they're both good
guys
you just described most crossover movies
see you got to start as a square one it
could be most
you can't build a castle yeah
they start our best friends
yes there is a discord kevin shepard oh
it's through our patreon i think
yeah that would be good i think they
should try to make a hellboy show
i think that would be cool you know they
have cyborg as one of the main
characters on doom patrol
and i didn't know how that would work
for a tv show because it's easy they'll
never
acknowledge it in the cinematic universe
well no i'm saying that like
cyborg injustice league movie he's all
cgi and then he's practical
and oh i see and doom patrol and at
times it looks a little goofy but for
the most part i'm like yeah i still
prefer it over the [ __ ] cgi
well and a hellboy i think would be
expensive but it could work
i think it'd be a cool show you'd have
to get i mean if you got
del toro pearlman would come back and i
bet he would do it for not
a ton uh but yeah it's funny uh
yeah that cgi i think that is a thing
especially with something like a cyborg
where you can fathom it and you can see
like you know metal and and all that
stuff i feel like having a slightly
campier practical is
is just gonna fill in the blank better
yeah because you just know that he's
covered in green
in the movie movie we're going to wrap
this up in a tiny bit
the littlest bit but let's see here
but but but but wait
cm this is your first time watching us
live really oh my goodness
welcome how was it did you with my hair
like this do you approve
i'm sorry hey eric i'm just gonna we're
just gonna read over it's gonna be
responding
thank you for everyone who's
contributing the super chats and the
stream labs it's meant a lot
now let's read off let's respond to some
answers here then we're going to end
this stream
all right guys get a speed round in here
speed round
quick answers q and a quick answers
hip-hop cinematic universe let's do it
supernatural in twilight and the
brothers hunt everyone
oh i love that concept
yes gorilla's cinematic universe i want
that kevin shepherd also i mean
song machine is great anissa i
appreciate that super chat i love you
all and she says and thank you for
today's live
anissa we love you and i appreciate you
guys putting up
with a very out of it greg the last hour
of his livestream
okay and not out of it greg and like ooh
greg's all loopy now he's just loose
and i'm more like no i'm i've reached
out of it
yeah i need some cheese
okay greg i got your back the board game
cinematic universe from jose cruz
universe jumanji zathura and clue i mean
you can't talk about jumanji any longer
without a hundred people showing up to
go so
it's technically part three so uh you
know that definitely
work clue i would just love to see come
back no matter how they do it
i'm not sure about spawn in the
cinematic universe
in the mcu i like the idea of what
they're doing with blumhouse
richard bentley what is your terrible
rap please repost it
richard bentley i don't think sylvester
you're so sweet
mimi you're so sweet where's your
terrible mirror now you're so great
ryan ready you're so awesome chill level
tv
who wants a compliment just say
something and greg's got you md
slush cedric my god you're better
looking than i could have ever imagined
ah matthew agastini
just just give me your sheepy you make
me feel relaxed
msd lush i actually your moral combat
bringing some cthulhu verse into mortal
kombat would be cool
matthew augustine would love to see a
cinematic universe of
grace randolph's superbia hey yeah
that's cool man
kevin shepherd sorry to take up time but
i just want to stress how confused i was
when my dad watched an episode of my cat
from hell completely out of nowhere and
i was watching the stream
my mind was blown oh that's funny how'd
the episode turn out
is it okay did you did they how they do
condensing a week's worth of
non-stop 24-hour footage into 20 minutes
how'd it turn out oh it's okay duh
noodle
erica i love you tm i love you too yeah
i love you rizzo
you are like a flower
waiting to be plucked from the womb
of the virgin area
uh bring the savage dragon and
shadowhawk to the big screen all right
richard bentley finally got his his rap
in here oh here we go i may be a nerd
but i'm not
unheard you read my comments all in your
contents i'm so glad you guys are red
i'm proud to be a part of this community
it's a great opportunity
it's nice oh nice man oh [ __ ] i gotta
get going
anissa's uh olivia's mad at me
i'm sorry all right guys well
duty calls i gotta move my car that's
right
and and i have to leave this place
have a good one this has been so much
fun and weird and bizarre
as expected thank you for thanking
everyone who contributed today
thank you for spending time and for
supporting my cat from hell
you be safe out there go watch my cat
from hell the best tv show in the world
best teeth in the game i'm gonna go get
something that's not chips
and then go to bed
love you guys thank you